Hallo.
Ja, schönen guten Tag, ich bin Hendrik.
Hallo Hendrik, ich bin
Kilian.
Kennen wir uns?
Ich weiß nicht, da war mal was.
Da kommen wir so vage in Erinnerungen. Ich war glaube ich schon mal hier.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher. Ist eine Weile her.
Ich kannte mal einen Kilian.
Mit dem habe ich mal einen Podcast aufgenommen.
Hatte mal, das kommt mir aber auch bekannt vor.
War ich das?
Ja, hi Kilian.
Hey, ich bin wieder da.
Du bist wieder zurück.
Und du bist in Dresden.
Ja, ich bin flüssig vor Ort.
Sehr schön.
Akronomisierbar, ich kriege immer die Zahlen nicht hin.
Akronomisierbar Folge 28.
Warte mal, jetzt muss ich auf akronomisier.baden.
Ich prüfe es auch gerade an.
ob es überhaupt stimmt.
Die letzte, warum läden die jetzt nicht?
Da kommt nix.
Feed.
Hast du die Webseite nicht verlängert?
Doch, doch, doch. Wir sind bei 28, stimmt schon.
Seite lädt auch. Alles gut.
Da kommt wirklich nichts bei mir, das bleibt weiß.
Also,
akronomisierbar, Folge 28.
Nehmt mich beim Wort.
Die sieht aber anders aus.
Ja, aber
unfreiwillig. Simplecast hat das
Jannert-Team geändert. Schreinerei.
ja, wir sind endlich wieder zum ersten Mal
seit Monaten wieder im gleichen Raum
und nehmen eine Podcast-Folge auf, natürlich bei der erstmöglichen
Gelegenheit. Kilian ist wieder zurück in Dresden.
Schön, dass du wieder da bist. Was hast du eigentlich gemacht
das letzte Halb? Das hat mir in der letzten Folge, wo ich da war,
also was ist denn das, Folge 25 gewesen, im September letztes Jahr,
mal kurz angesprochen, ich habe ein Praktikum gemacht bei so einer
Obstfirma in weit weg, so over
9000 Kilometer away.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich habe bei Apple ein Praktikum gemacht
und zwar habe ich am Swift Package Manager
gearbeitet. Abgefahren. Was sehr
cool war. Wir haben es uns empfehlen,
sowas mal zu machen. War sehr interessant,
vor allem, weil es ein Open-Source-Projekt
war in einer Firma, die dafür bekannt ist,
dass man nichts darüber sagen darf, was man
dort so macht und was passiert intern.
Deswegen darf ich natürlich auch nichts
über Interne erzählen, logischerweise.
Aber mein Projekt ist
komplett Open-Source, das heißt, darüber kann ich sehr
reden. Nur nicht halt, wie das
entsteht. Aber ich meine, nur mal so
Meta, und unterbrich mich, wenn ich jetzt
irgendwas erzähle, was du wahrscheinlich nicht beantworten darfst,
aber du bist nach San Francisco,
nee, also nach Cupertino
gezogen. Also ein Stadtteil oder ein
Kleinstadtteil von San Jose. Das ist ein Vorort
von, ja genau. Und
dort hast du in so einer Art
Jugendherberge gewohnt?
Nee, das war offiziell Corporate
Housing, also von Apple gestellte Wohnung.
Gehört nicht Apple, ist
aber exakt neben dem Apple Park.
so eine typisch amerikanische
in Anführungsstrichen Community,
was so wie so quasi
ein paar eingegrenzte Häuser
mit einem Zaun drumherum, wo ein
Leasing-Office davor steht, wo
haufenweise Leute wohnen und auch gerade
weil Apple das eben da sich gut mit einmietet,
auch ein paar Interns mit untergebracht hat.
Das war nicht nur für Interns, aber
da waren schon gut eine Menge Interns.
Normalerweise ist das
Praktika, der Zeitraum,
wo die ganzen Praktikanten, ich werde jetzt Interns und Praktikanten
einfach mal wechseln,
mal ständig hin und her.
Zur Ruhe, intern, wir haben jetzt definiert, dass der Begriff intern praktikant heißt.
Aber was ist denn ein Leasing-Office?
Das ist quasi ein Office,
was zu dieser Community gehört, wo die das managen.
Da gehst du hin, wenn du Probleme hast,
da gehst du hin, wenn du eine Führung haben willst,
du willst hier hinziehen.
Und die sind einfach quasi verantwortlich für die Community.
Quasi, aber das ist wirklich so ein eigenständiges Ding.
Weird, weil das eben abgezäunt ist drumherum.
Du kommst nur mit einem Code rein, der ist
2, 3, 3 Pfund, falls da jemand dringehen möchte.
Ach, das darfst du sagen, ja.
Das ist gar kein Grund,
Die Hunden waren eh alle kaputt, da gibt es immer eine, die gerade offen ist.
Okay, also wenn ihr ein Cupertino von Apple-Praktikanten Laptops klauen wollt, macht das nicht.
Aber es war ganz cool, weil das halt wirklich exakt neben dem Apple Park ist.
Ich war wirklich gewohnt auf der Mitte vom Apple Maps Icon.
Wenn du auf das Apple Maps Icon schaust, dann siehst du in der Ecke den Apple Park, also einen Kreis.
Ich zeige es dir einfach mal hier.
Dieser Kreis da oben ist der Apple Park.
Der blaue Pfeil fährt gerade über die Wolf Road, über den Freeway 280 rüber.
Und direkt auf dieser grünen Fläche, da rechts oben von dem Pfeil, da sind die Hemdons.
Das hat das Eichen hier schön unseren Tisch fallen lassen, dass da noch ein paar Häuser stehen.
Ach, das hast du mal vertwittert, dass du quasi dort, wo du wohnst, ist quasi das Apple Maps Icon.
Genau, das ist die Mitte vom Apple Maps Icon.
Aber es ist recht cool, weil du halt genau die Apple Park, wie gesagt, wohnst.
Du kannst einfach mal da rüber gehen.
Das war am Anfang noch nicht offen für alle Mitarbeiter, weil das Gebäude noch quasi in der Einzugsphase war.
Aber das ging dann irgendwann Ende 2018, haben die das dann aufgemacht, da konnte er auch als Mitarbeiter da eben durchlaufen, mal umschauen. Das ist schon beeindruckend, vor allem ein sehr rundes Gebäude. Du gehst halt im Kreis rum und da gibt es halt so ein paar, ich sag mal, so Ausfahrten, Exits quasi, wo du bestimmte Wege rausnehmen kannst und du weißt halt nicht genau, wenn du dich dadurch auskennst, wo du lang möchtest. Und es sieht alles fucking identisch aus, weil es ein runder Kreis ist. Du gehst einfach nur immer im selben Winkel rum und sagst, okay, wo bin ich gerade?
Das muss so ein bisschen sein, wie wenn man um den Rand der flachen Erde geht.
Ja genau, die Flight-Earther werden das ja besser auskennen.
Ich bin da auch mal rumgestrobert, als ich letztes Jahr auf Dienstreise in Kalifornien war und ich dachte, kann ich ja mal reingehen irgendwo?
Dann bin ich dann bei, wie heißt das hier, Infinite Loop One?
Das ist ein alter Headquarter, genau.
Da gehen ganz viele Leute ein und ausschaut mal.
Und dann ist mir so eine Security angesprochen, ja schönen guten Tag, darf ich mal dein iPhone sein?
Ich habe kein iPhone.
Aber ist ja eine Badge-Szene oder was?
Ja, und dann habe ich gesagt, ach nee, wisst ihr was, ich habe das von zu Hause vergessen.
Ich gehe mal wieder.
Dann bin ich zu Google gefahren und habe mir da die Fahrräder angeguckt.
Nice.
Ja, cool. Das war also das, wo du gewohnt hast?
Ich habe da gewohnt, aber nicht im Apple Park gearbeitet.
Das war in einem anderen Gebäude.
Sonst hätte ich da auch am Anfang schon reingedürft.
Das wäre ein bisschen Quatsch.
Also ich bin jeden Tag durch den Apple Park durchgelatscht,
um auf der anderen Seite vom Apple Park das Shuttle zu nehmen
und dann mit dem Apple Shuttle da zehn Minuten durch Cupertino zu fahren
und dann zu meinem Gebäude.
Was ich sehr angenehm fand, weil in meinem Gebäude hatten die Mitarbeiter auch einzelne Offices.
Also ich hatte zuerst eins alleine, weil wir eine ungerade Anzahl an Leute in dem Team waren.
Aber später habe ich mir eins geteilt.
Und im Apple Park, wo es ist halt, es ist kein Großraumoffice, aber es sind glaube ich schon Fünfer, Fünfernräume.
Und für Praktikanten gerade manchmal sogar noch ein paar mehr.
Also mein Mitbewohner hat dort wohl, glaube ich, an einem Tisch mit 20 anderen Leuten gesessen.
Das ist das eine so eine lange Tafel, wo man so zehn nebeneinander hat, auf der Gegenüberlieben und Seiten nochmal zehn.
So hat er es zumindest beschrieben.
Ich habe sein Büro nie gesehen.
Das ist ein bisschen krass.
Bei uns haben sie die Büros währenddessen umgebaut.
Da war auch so die Befürchtung, dass wir so ein Großraumbüro kriegen,
weil sich die Firma das gerne so gewünscht hätte.
Da haben wir natürlich ein bisschen protestiert nach dem Motto,
wir wollen noch zum Arbeiten kommen.
Jetzt haben wir aber Räume für bis zu zehn Leute,
wo allerdings momentan bloß so sechs drin sitzen.
Das geht noch für nichts.
Da kommen wir noch zurecht bei einer kleinen Anzahl von Leuten.
Man muss sich allerdings, wenn man sich unterhalten will,
wirklich immer mal zusammenreißen
und dann irgendwie in den Nachbarn gehen
oder sich so einen Huddle-Room nehmen und sowas.
Das macht schon einen Unterschied.
Und gerade ich, der ich doch
des Häufigeren mal ein Meeting habe und dabei dann auch
laut rede, kriege ich ab und zu mal so ein Psst.
Das ist auch verständlich.
Ich meine, wenn Leute hinter dir rumprabbeln anfangen,
dann ist es natürlich schwierig, da sich zu konzentrieren.
Ich hätte das gleiche Problem, wenn die ganze Zeit Leute um mich
rum telefonieren. Das ist ja gerade das, worüber ich mich
beschwert. Wenn die ganze Zeit Leute um mich
rum telefonieren würden, würde ich auch wahnsinnig werden.
Dann könnte ich auch keine Zeitle-Code schreiben.
Dann komme ich gar nicht in die Zone rein.
Oder anders, wenn Leute zusammenarbeiten wollen,
nämlich Pair-Programming an einem Tisch machen
und da sitzen an dem gleichen Tisch in Hörer,
ich weiß, wir sitzen aber auch nochmal fünf andere Leute,
die sich davon dann stören lassen,
dann kannst du quasi auch gar kein Pair-Programming mehr machen.
Das geht dann halt schwierig, das stimmt.
Und wie war das bei dir?
Hast du irgendwie mit anderen Leuten zusammengearbeitet
oder haben sie dir was auf den Tisch gelegt und gesagt,
mach du das mal?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sehr ich da ins Detail gehen darf,
aber ich glaube, ich kann sagen,
dass ich prinzipiell größtenteils an meinem Projekt alleine gearbeitet habe,
aber natürlich jederzeit diverse Hilfestellungen hatte.
Also ich konnte natürlich immer auf Leute zugehen
und Leute haben sich auch wirklich Zeit genommen,
das Problem zu verstehen und mir zu helfen.
Aber prinzipiell war es,
also sicherlich lag es auch an meiner Arbeitsweise,
dass ich mich da eher hingesetzt habe
und versucht habe, so weit wie möglich da rumzubasteln,
bis es halt irgendwann lief.
Was manchmal ein bisschen witzig war,
weil ich dann an einem Problem zumindest ein bisschen länger gekaut habe
und dann hat sich ein Kollege das angeschaut,
der macht das so, so, so.
Oh, okay, ja, das stimmt.
Ich sitze da schon seit einer Woche dran, aber okay, danke.
Ja, das sind so die Sachen, die man
du hast ja, hast du schon mal
überhaupt in einer größeren Firma?
Das war für mich auch eben ein Novum quasi
Das sind so die Sachen, die du lernst
wenn du bei einer Firma anfängst
Kommunikation hilft
Man schämt sich vielleicht auch so ein bisschen
man denkt auch immer so, die anderen kennen das alles schon
oder die könnten das alles
und ich mach das nur, weil die anderen schon so beschäftigt sind
und ich frag die mal lieber überhaupt nicht
weil die machen total wichtige Sachen
Ja, genau das
Aber ist gar nicht so.
Wenn du da hinkriegst und sagst,
ich bin ja gerade an dem,
was würdest du da?
Ich weiss da jetzt nicht weiter.
Oder hast du das schon mal?
Das muss man erstmal überwinden.
Das stimmt.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich da wirklich
hundertprozentig irgendwo hingekommen bin,
aber ich habe diesen Gedanken auf jeden Fall mit der Kopf,
dass man da mehr mit Leuten sprechen sollte.
Das hilft.
Und auch generell ist das halt cool,
weil bei Apple arbeiten auch erstaunlich viele Nerds.
Wer hätte es gedacht?
Ach, also es war an manchen Stellen jetzt nicht optisch, so das Congress-Feeling, weil natürlich nichts groß blinkt und dunkel und cool ist.
Also cool schon, aber du hast nicht diese Atmosphäre von, ich sitze abends auf dem Congressrum, aber du hast die Leute, die dort halt quasi auch hingehen würden.
Und die halt auch dieselben Storys auspacken, jetzt beim Mittagessen oder halt einfach nur, wenn du dich darauf ansprichst.
Und einfach so witziger, historischer Kram, den du immer gewusst haben wolltest, wie irgendwelche alte Hardware zustande kamen.
keine Ahnung, ich hatte zwei Kollegen, die
im WebObjects-Team früher
gearbeitet haben, vor 20 Jahren, als sie da angefangen
haben. WebObjects.
Also das ist Apples altes Web-Framework,
was zumindest der
URL nach immer noch für den iTunes-Store
eingesetzt wird. Da wird mich wahrscheinlich jemand hauen,
der das besser weiß.
So was wird auch selten deprecated. Wenn das einmal läuft, dann läuft es.
Aber das ist halt sonst niemand mehr und das war mal der
geilste Scheiß schlechthin.
Und hat vieles
richtig gemacht. Das ist ein cooles Zeug, kann man auf jeden Fall mal reinschauen,
wie die Dinge gemacht haben.
Aber die Leute, die da halt ewig dran gearbeitet haben,
die da wirklich den historischen Kontext dazu erzählen können.
Und auch von so einem Schreien in irgendeinem Apple-Gebord
erzählen, wo du mal hingehen kannst,
dann steht da so ein paar Awards, die die da was bekommen haben
und alte Verpackungen und so ein T-Shirt.
Cool, das hat schon was.
Also es ist doch kein großer, seelenloser Komplex,
wo nur an und über Leute arbeiten.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
So fühlt sich das überhaupt nicht an.
Das fand ich auch echt angenehm.
das habe ich meinem Manager auch gesagt zum Ende hin,
wo er so ein bisschen generelles Feedback von mir haben wollte,
dass ich die
Firmenkultur intern sehr
zugänglich und freundlich finde.
Also generell hast du ja,
gut, im Englischen ist das
irgendwo ein Given, aber du hast halt direkt das
Du mit jedem. Aber du sprichst
Leute halt auch nicht mit dem Nachnamen an, sondern jeder ist
direkt Vornamen. Egal, wer
der in der Firma ist, wenn ich auf Craig Federici
treffe, Apples Head of Software, der direkt
nach Tim Cook steht, Hi Craig.
Das ist halt direkt,
Das ist halt ein fester Teil der Schwirmkultur.
Das war schon immer so, das wird immer so sein.
Und das macht es halt so viel einfacher,
mit Leuten intern direkt auf ein Level zu kommen,
wo man mit denen super reden kann.
Das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen diese amerikanische Nonchalance.
Vielleicht auch das.
Aber gerade bei Apple ist es halt stärker als bei anderen großen Firmen.
Also bei den Tech-Firmen ist es wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Bei Microsoft kann ich mir so nicht so vorstellen.
Bei Oracle ist es wahrscheinlich das krasse Gegenteil,
dass es da ganz anders ausschaut.
Wenn du jemanden ansprichst,
dann wirst du direkt verklagt vom internen Legal-Team wahrscheinlich.
Aber das ist halt Oracle.
Ich habe eigentlich gerade, nachdem wir über Leutefragen
geredet hatten, nach einem Tweet gesucht, der das
neulich mal sehr schön zusammengefasst hatte,
den kann ich, finde ich allerdings gerade nicht.
Und zwar hat er eine geschrieben, das große Problem bei
Engineers untereinander beim Zusammenarbeiten
ist eigentlich, dass die
Leute entweder
so ein crippling Ego
haben, dass sie einfach die absoluten
Ego-Typen sind, oder dass sie
crippling Imposter-Syndrom haben.
Und da muss man so
eine Waage zwischen finden.
Also Mittelding wäre schon das optimalste
aber du hast glaube ich recht, die meisten Leute hängen
mehr auf einem
Extrem, auf einem der beiden Extrema dieser Seite,
dieser Skala.
Das stimmt schon, da ist was dran. Witzig.
Ja, und dein Projekt war was?
Was hast du eigentlich gemacht?
Ich habe, wie ich meinte, am Swift Package Manager
gearbeitet. Also mein Team hat,
das ist glaube ich,
ja doch, das kann ich sagen,
wir haben unter anderem am Swift Package Manager
gearbeitet
und da waren ein paar
Projektideen, um die ich mich
habe kümmern können und wir haben am Anfang mal evaluiert, was so ein cooles Projekt wäre und bei Apple ist es generell so, dass du als Praktikant, also nicht generell, aber so in 99% der Fälle, kriegst du als Praktikant ein Projekt und nicht, hier fix mal Bugs. Und das ist halt sehr cool. Du kriegst halt was, was du selber auf die Beine stellst.
Das ist extrem wichtig.
Ja, eben. Du kriegst natürlich Unmengen an Hilfe, aber du hast am Ende was, wo du sagen kannst, wo du drauf zeigen kannst, das da, das habe ich gemacht. Und das ist so cool. Und so habe ich dann am Ende einen neuen Dependency Resolver für den Swift Package Manager gebastelt.
Und zwar hat der Alte ein paar Nachteile, beziehungsweise eben auch der Aktuelle, hoffentlich nicht mehr lange der Aktuelle, der Default, der kann nämlich zum einen sehr, sehr lange brauchen in ein paar Extremfällen. Also wenn der Dependency Graph komplexer wird, dann kann das schon mal so, ich brauche so 10 Minuten zum Resolven.
Und wenn der Dependency Graph sehr komplex wird,
ich brauche so
drei Tage, um zu resorven.
Okay.
Das ist meistens halt Extremfall und das Problem ist halt auch,
dass der mögliche Fehlerquellen
nicht finden kann.
Und der andere Nachteil ist halt,
manchmal ist ein Dependency Graph unresolvable.
Das geht halt nicht immer auf.
Wann ist denn ein Dependency Graph nicht resolvable?
Wenn du zum Beispiel
Version-Konflicts hast, die sich nicht lösen lassen.
Das geht einfach nicht so, wie du die...
Das heißt, ich habe eine Abhängigkeit A
B und beide hängen
selber ab von unterschiedlichen Versionen von Abhängigkeit
C? Zum Beispiel. Und die sind
nicht miteinander kompatibel, egal wie du es drehst.
Dann kannst du das nicht resorgen.
Du kannst in Swift auch immer nur
eine Version von einer Dependency
auf irgendeinem Pfad importieren?
Mit einer Version meinst du eine Fest-December-Version?
Ja, oder eine kompatible Version.
Du kannst halt Ranges angeben.
Du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, wie gesagt, ich habe
Versionen, zwei
Sachen haben,
SSL drin oder irgendwas anderes,
was so total generisch ist, aber das eine Ding hat
Version 1 und das andere hat Version 2,
die komplett inkompatibel sind, kann ich nicht beide
mit reinnehmen. Nee, das geht nicht.
Also das geht in JavaScript ja zum Beispiel,
weil das einfach so dynamisch ist, dass das kein
Problem ist, was aber super weird ist,
sobald du ein Problem damit hast und das zu debuggen, weil
viel Spaß. Also viel
Spaß dabei. Das ist sehr
unschön zu durchsehen. Ich glaube, Rust
hat dafür jetzt einen sehr interessanten Weg gefunden,
dass die, glaube ich, wie man es genannt hat,
das kann ich nicht mehr auf den Titel.
Bei JavaScript geht es, weil du es in unterschiedlichen
ähm, da hast du ja nicht das perfekte
Thema gefunden, Paketmanager.
Ja eben, nee, ich finde es aber
großartig, weil es liegt mir halt sehr am Herzen.
Es war Open Source, es ist kein Swift-Schreiben.
Das war halt wirklich
Punktlandung auf das Projekt.
Das war nicht so toll.
Bei Rust ist es so, dass die unterschiedlichen
Sachen dann halt unterschiedliche Typen sind.
Das Hauptproblem, woran es bei C und C++
scheitert, ist, dass einfach dieser
Namespace von den Symbolen alles
eine ein Ding ist, bei
JavaScript, wenn du es mit
Node resolvst, dann resolvst du jede Datei
von ihrer lokalen Position
aus in ihrem Node-Modul verzeichnet
und weiß gar nicht, dass sie selber Dependency von was
Größerem ist und schaut immer bloß nach unten,
das geht. Wenn du das dann
packagst mit Webpack, dann schreiben sie auch immer
diese kompletten Pfade immer weiter noch mit dran,
das heißt, der komplette Pfadname
gehört weiterhin zur Signatur und du kannst doppelt,
dreifach, zehn, drei. Aber das kann trotzdem,
da gab es irgendwelche Möglichkeiten, wie du das kaputt
machen kannst aus Versehen.
Das fällt mir gerade kein Beispiel an, wie das zustande kommen könnte.
Aber ich meine, da gab es auf jeden Fall irgendwas,
wie das kaputt gehen kann.
Aber bei Rust hatte ich eben was dazu gelesen,
dass man da angeblich den Weg genommen hat
zwischen Shared Dependencies und die,
das Name fällt mir gerade nicht ein,
die du halt kapselst nur für deine Library,
die halt quasi intern für diese Library sind,
die nicht nach außen weiter exportiert werden.
Und dementsprechend können die halt gekapselt da drin liegen,
ohne von draußen irgendwie angefasst zu werden.
Und dann ist es halt egal,
weil du das da in den Namespaces reinlegst,
ohne dass es exportet wird
und Probleme führen kann
mit anderen Versionen von demselben Ding.
In Swift geht das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Die Dinge müssen eindeutig,
du darfst nur eine Version von einem Package
der kompletten Namespace
drin haben.
Und da kannst du halt dazu auf jeden Fall
zu Anvisore-Graphen kommen oder zu Graphen,
die sich nicht auflösen lassen. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Möglichkeiten,
nicht lösebare Graphen zu haben. Vielleicht hast du einfach
eine Version genommen, die nicht existiert.
Logisch, dann geht's nicht. Du kannst halt spezifizieren, was du
ist in dein Manifest, aber kann halt trotzdem dazu führen,
dass es nicht geht. Und der aktuelle
Resolver im Swift Package Manager,
der kann dir halt nicht erklären,
warum es schiefgegangen ist. Normalerweise sagt er
bloß, ging nicht,
schau mal, könnte das Paket sein, keine Ahnung.
Das ist halt alles, was er
in Fehlermeldung hat. Und das ist auch das Coole
an dem Neuen, den haben wir halt basieren lassen
auf einem Algorithmus namens PubGrab.
Also ich habe nicht den Algorithmus selber entwickelt, ich habe den quasi
nur implementiert.
Anfangs war der Gedanke, ja, machen wir das
vielleicht in den ersten drei Monaten
und in den zweiten drei Monaten ein anderes Projekt.
Nach sechs Monaten war so,
das erste Projekt ist fast fertig.
Ja, wie es halt immer so ist.
Ja, genau. Aber das ist basiert auf einem Algorithmus
namens PubCrop. Das ist der Dependency
Resolution Algorithmus, den
ein paar Entwickler von Pub,
Darts Package Manager, unter anderem
die Natalie Weizenbaum,
entwickelt haben.
Der wird dort schon verwendet und
der hat ein paar sehr coole
Möglichkeiten damit umzugehen. Zum einen ist
Also es ist prinzipiell erstmal ein Sat-Solver, den der abbildet bzw. implementiert und das ganze Problem halt auf der Ebene löst, dass du das quasi abbildest als ein typisches Boolean-Satisfiability-Problem und dann das versuchst zu lösen.
Also prinzipiell ist es satt.
Und das Witzige daran ist, dass du da halt sehr coole Optimierungen fahren kannst, was die Problemlösungsstrategie angeht.
was wir vorher drin hatten, war halt einfach
ein Brute Force Ansatz, der wirklich alles
durchprobiert. Und der
braucht halt dementsprechend in manchen Fällen
sehr, sehr lange. Wenn du halt
auf sehr viele Versionen von sehr vielen
Dependencies in deinem Graphen drin hast, dann
kann das schon mal so ein paar Millionen, Milliarden
Checks machen müssen. Und das
zieht sich halt. Und das Problem
ist halt zusätzlich noch, dass Swift
ja seine Manifestdatei in Swift
definiert. Ja, das heißt, du kannst das nicht ohne weiteres
mal scannen. Eben, du musst die quasi
ausführen, also nicht quasi, du musst die ausführen,
das Manifest, um zu wissen, was die Liste
an Dependencies ist. Und das musst du halt für jede Version
dann neu machen, weil jede Version könnte ja auf ein
anderes Set an Dependencies dependen.
Und dann fängst du immer wieder bei
Null an, weil das nicht auf einmal...
Aber der Aufwand geht halt ins
Unermessliche irgendwann hoch.
Und durch PubGrab kannst du da halt wirklich viele Sachen
schon ausschließen. Wenn du weißt, dass du diese Version
niemals nehmen kannst, dann kannst du
die quasi aus deinem Dependency-Graph rausstreichen.
Alles, was da unten noch dran baumelt, an diesem Graphen
weiter an diesem, also
ist letztendlich
ein Tree an Dependencies, den du da hast
und wenn du da quasi wirklich
einen Teil damit wegstreichen kannst, dann beschließt du
viele Möglichkeiten, die der Blutforce-Resolver
noch mit anschauen müsste, komplett aus
und minimierst
halt den Arbeitsaufwand um ein Vielfaches,
schon im Vorhinein. Und das ist halt super praktisch
und gleichzeitig baust du
dir halt noch einen Graphen auf, was die
finale Lösung angeht und wenn du
irgendwann zu dem Punkt kommst, wo du siehst, es gibt
keine Lösung für diesen
für diesen spezifischen Graphen.
Dann gehst du diesen Graphen, den du aufgebaut hast,
um die Lösung zu finden, einfach wieder durch
und kannst darauf ergehend erklären, warum es keine Lösung gibt.
Weil das Paket in der Version, mit dem Paket in der Version und so weiter.
Und hast am Ende halt wirklich eine Erklärung,
die halt für den Entwickler,
also wir haben es nur mal Actionable genannt,
also dass der Entwickler halt sehen kann,
was ist das Problem und was muss ich jetzt tun,
um dieses Problem zu lösen.
Für Actionable kenne ich auch kein deutsches Wort.
Nee, mir fällt auch spontan nichts ein.
Das ist cool, aber das klingt jetzt so, als ob du quasi,
wenn man entweder, was war es,
wenn man jetzt
dem Swift-Package-Manager beibringen würde,
dass er anstatt, wie heißen die dann,
Package.swift?
Ja, genau.
Package-Swift.json-Dateien zu lesen,
könnte man schon mal ein Problem erschlagen,
wenn man das erlauben würde,
dass man das auch nebeneinander legt.
Und wenn man dann auch noch der Sprache beibringen würde,
dass es einfach mehrere Versionen
von einer Dependency einbauen kann,
dann wäre es quasi...
Das sehe ich gar nicht mal so notwendig,
mehrere Versionen der Dependency.
das ist nicht so das Problem, was man eigentlich haben,
also tacklen müsste.
Also wenn man das hat, dann macht es
vieles, ich will nicht sagen, also es macht es
natürlich einfacher,
komische Graphen zu nutzen, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob das für das
große Ganze hilfreich wäre, weil
es halt auch sehr weirde Situationen hervorführen
würde. Und das Modul für das System von
Zwift gibt es halt aktuell einfach nicht her, deswegen geht
das auch aktuell noch nicht. Ich nehme
noch vorsichtiger an der Stelle, weil ich weiß nicht, ob ich möchte,
dass es irgendwann geht oder ob da Interesse
dran steht, besteht, dass es überhaupt
Es kann ja auch zu riesigen Binarys führen.
Eben, du kannst ja dann die Anfang-Dependencies
aus Versehen halt 15 Mal mit reinzupacken.
Dann hast du eine Facebook-App, die halt ihre Abhängigkeiten
30 Mal reinzieht, weil er gegen das Team so gemacht hat.
Bei Rust weiß ich, dass
viele Sachen zum Beispiel von Serda
abhängen. Das hast du nicht in jeder Anwendung,
bloß weil deine Dependencies das können,
35.000 Mal Serda drin, die scheinen das auch irgendwie
sauber aufzulösen. Ja, es gibt ja auch Möglichkeiten,
ich glaube Tree Shaking heißt das, wo du halt die Sachen,
die nicht gebraucht werden, am Ende wieder rausschüttelst,
weil du siehst, dass die gar nicht gebraucht werden.
Da gibt es ja auch Möglichkeiten, das zu reduzieren.
Und ich weiß diese eine Sache mit,
warum ist das und das jetzt kaputt, an welcher Stelle?
Ich weiß ja auch, dass das was ist.
Das gibt es zum Beispiel bei NPM, da gibt es dieses
NPM-Y. Das ist herrlich.
Ich habe hier in meinem Node-Module
irgendwie das und das. Warum zum Geier
brauche ich das? Oder du machst so
einen Audit-Aufruf und dann siehst du irgendwie,
ja, du hast ein Problem, weil
es gibt eine Security-Vulnerability in der
Dependency von der Dependency von der Dependency.
Warum zum Geier brauche ich jetzt hier
Leftpad zum Beispiel.
Und dann kannst du dir so einen schönen,
das malt dir dann schöne Graphen von
deiner Anwendung über die ganzen Dependencies
bis zu der Dependency, die du gerade
erfragst. So was wollte ich mal für
Cargo bauen, aber
da war der Abend schon ein bisschen zu spät und ich hab's
nochmal abgebrochen. Das ist zumindest was, was dort noch fehlt.
Ich hab mir das mal für Homebrew
kurz zusammengescriptet. Einfach nur,
also die Idee, die ähnliche, aber es war eher so,
dieses Paket ist auf einem System installiert.
Warum? Also gar nicht mal so sehr,
das ist eine Dependency von irgendwas anderem, sondern
warum habe ich das installiert?
Ich hätte gern, dass mir
dieser Commander, meine Shell-History,
die hoffentlich niemals gebrod wird, einfach
durchgeht und mir Kontext gibt, wann
ich das installiert habe. Und zwar erstmal
die drei Zeilen drumherum. Was habe ich da
gemacht gerade? Warum habe ich das Paket installiert? Also kann
er ja nicht erklären, was meine Intention dahinter war.
Aber mir halt zeigen, in welchem Kontext ich mich da befand,
wann das war und so weiter.
In welchem Director ich mich vielleicht befand.
Einfach so, um mir irgendwie, warum habe ich
das mal installiert? Brauche ich das
überhaupt noch? Arbeit ich noch
was damals relevant war.
Bei Arch kannst du dann in die
Pac-Man-Log-Datei gucken,
weil der Paketmanager in den Log schreibt,
wann er was installiert.
Ich finde, der Homebook macht das sogar auch irgendwie
ganz cool irgendwo. Ich habe es einfach nicht gesehen,
aber ich habe einfach mal ein bisschen Kontext aus meiner
Z-Chall-History rausgezogen.
Das ist immer schwierig.
Was geil wäre bei der Z-Chall-History, wenn man dir auch noch
in der History schreiben würde,
was das PWD gerade war,
also in welchem Ort du gerade wärst.
Dann denkst du so, warum habe ich das gemacht?
und dann suchst du das CD
10 Zeilen vorher, wenn du da in den Ordner reingegangen bist
oder so. Ja, also wüsste ich da gerne noch
alle PWDs von allen offenen Terminal Sessions,
weil ich oftmals ein zweites Tab aufmache,
nur um schnell was zu installieren.
Stimmt, wenn du dann ein neues Fenster oder ein neues Tab aufmachst,
dann hast du natürlich kein CD dazu, sondern bist einfach so
in dem Ordner. Beziehungsweise du bist halt
einfach in einem Home Directory, je nachdem was du halt machst gerade
und installierst da was nach, schließt das Tab wieder
und gehst wieder zurück ins andere.
Wäre ich halt auch oft. Also wäre schon cool,
wenn man da irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Kontext zu graben.
speichern könnte. Auf jeden Fall.
Aber ja, also du hast zusammen
ein paar Swift Package Manager gebaut und hast
einen neuen
Graph Resolving
Algorithmus, Dependency Resolving Algorithmus
dort eingebaut, der quasi aus
der Dart-Welt kommt. Genau. Das fand ich
auch sehr cool, dass wir da halt quasi
Arbeit von Google Engineers
gesehen haben. Die haben halt auch sehr
öffentlich cool darüber geschrieben.
Es war quasi am Anfang ein Medium-Post,
den die geschrieben haben,
der sehr ausführlich das schon beschrieben hat, wie das
die können wir auch gerne mal mit in den Shownotes verlinken.
Auf jeden Fall.
Hast du da irgendwie
Prior Art zu recherchiert
oder hat das irgendwie dein
Praktikumsbetreuer schon sich überlegt,
dass man das so machen könnte?
Also die
Idee dafür war schon da.
Wir hatten halt ein paar Sachen
besprochen, was so ein cooles
Praktikumsprojekt wäre und da waren
ein paar Sachen auf jeden Fall zur Debatte gestanden, unter anderem
halt das und das, dann haben wir halt
da haben wir halt unter anderem besprochen, was den
größten Impact hätte und was
am interessantesten auch wäre und für
mich persönlich am interessantesten. Und
letztendlich sind wir darauf gelandet, dass das ein
super cooles Projekt wäre. Und so hat sich das
entschieden, grob.
Was halt sehr cool ist, ist, dass das Ganze halt schon
im Packet Training statt drin ist. Das heißt, wenn du
Xcode auf deinem System installiert hast, dann hast du
auf deinem System Code, den ich geschrieben habe,
was ich sehr cool und
gleichzeitig intimidating finde,
dass Millionen von Leuten jetzt Code von
wir auf jedem System haben.
Du musst es aber, ja genau, du musst es mit dem Feature-Flag
aktuell enablen, wenn du es nutzen kannst.
Das ist einfach, wenn du Swift Build oder Swift
Package Resolve ausführst, kannst du
dash dash enable dash pubgrab dash resolver mitgeben.
Okay, das packen wir mal in die Schuhe.
Genau, und da kannst du halt
das schon nutzen. Und das ist halt super cool,
weil es gibt einen öffentlichen Swift PM
Slack, wo auch ein paar Mitarbeiter drin sitzen.
Und da
gibt es halt irgendwie Leute, die halt Fragen haben, hier,
ich probiere hier gerade so ein Projekt aufzuziehen und irgendwie
entweder Resolve, der nicht fertig, oder der sagt,
und es geht nicht, warum geht denn das nicht?
Oder der hört einfach nicht auf, der macht da irgendwas
komisches. Und jetzt kannst du halt schon
das Flag nutzen, um zum Debuggen
zu helfen. Und kannst du halt das Flag mit,
der sagt dir, warum es nicht geht, dann fixst du das Problem
und nutzt halt aktuell dann wieder wahrscheinlich den
normalen Resolver, der halt zum selben Resultat dann schneller
kommt und keinen Fehler mehr hat, wie auch immer.
Bis halt irgendwann der Power Resolver, der
den anderen wirklich ersetzt.
Ach, der normale ist manchmal aber schneller?
Ne, der normale ist nicht schneller.
Der ist aber aktuell noch der Default eben.
Und also die meisten Leute wollen natürlich den Default
nutzen. Vor allem ist der halt tried and proven,
sodass er halt Probleme hat oder
haben kann. Der neue ist halt
immer schneller, manchmal
gleich schnell.
Also er wird nie langsamer. Das ist halt schon mal
sehr cool. Aber der wird halt
irgendwann zum Default. Wann, weiß ich nicht.
Kriegst du jetzt auch nicht mehr mit?
Also ich hab noch das Datum im Kopf, was wir halt geplant hatten,
als ich noch da war, aber das muss natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr
aktuell sein. Aber du bist jetzt quasi aus dem Entwicklungsprozess raus,
obwohl es Open Source ist? Ich bin komplett raus.
Also ich hab noch mal letztens geschaut, was
meine Kollegen noch weitergemacht haben. Da ist ja
das kann ich ja auch aufgetan. Aber es ist nicht so,
dass du da jetzt von außen kontributen könntest?
Ich könnte, problemlos. Ich habe auch
oftmals noch bekundet und mir wurde auch
von meinem Team noch gesagt, dass ich das auch gern gesehen würde,
wenn ich jetzt dadurch, dass ich halt mal drinstecke
und das Projekt
nicht unglaublich viele Contributor hat
weltweit, äh, weltweit,
in der Öffentlichkeit außerhalb von
Apple, wäre es cool, wenn ich da Bock
drauf hätte und ich habe auf jeden Fall sehr viel Lust,
noch weiter zu SwiftPM zu kontributen
und ich könnte das auch problemlos machen.
Einzige, was halt schwierig ist, ist, dass gewisse
interner, die halt mit dem Projekt verknüpft sind,
die kriegst du halt von außen nicht mit.
Und da kannst du auch nicht daran teilnehmen.
Und das ist halt ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber wenn du dich auf das beschränkst,
was halt wirklich nur öffentlich ist.
Also manchmal ist es halt,
du willst halt irgendein Feature bauen und das geht halt nicht.
Und dann kriegst du halt bloß mitgelegt,
ja, mach das mal nicht.
Cool.
Ja, das klingt jetzt viel schlimmer, als es eigentlich ist.
Aber es kann halt sein, dass gewisse Sachen,
wenn du halt ein größeres Feature planst,
wenn du jetzt der Meinung hättest,
der Square Package Runner braucht unbedingt Feature X
und du willst das Feature bauen, das ist irgendwas...
Package Chasen Support.
Zum Beispiel, fantastisch, mach das bitte nicht.
Du willst sowas machen
und baust halt schon mal einen riesigen PR,
ohne mit irgendjemandem drüber zu sprechen.
Ja, nee, dann kann es dir passieren.
Eben, das ist aber bei jedem Projekt eigentlich so.
Wenn du ein riesiges Feature einfach direkt versuchst zu landen,
das ist halt immer so, besprech das doch vorher mal.
Und red doch mal, wie sowas am besten reinpasst,
dann können wir da in der Community drüber reden.
Kommunikation.
halt auch nicht anders bei dem Projekt.
Das Technische ist das, was man schon
mitbringen sollte oder zum großen Teil
mitbringen sollte und gerade wenn man zum ersten Mal
in so einer Firma arbeitet,
wo mehrere Leute an der Codebase arbeiten und nicht
bloß man selbst an der
kleinen Hobby-Codebase,
dann ist das Kommunizieren
was, was man am ehesten lernen muss.
Auf jeden Fall, das stimmt. Da steigt man auch
ein paar Wochen, bevor man
in einer Firma von der Größe, glaube ich, auch durchsteigt, was es
überhaupt an den Ressourcen gibt. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Das fand ich schon cool.
Kommunikationswege und...
Ja, nice, krass.
Nee, war cool. Also generell
auch die Gegend war cool.
Es hat auf jeden Fall mal Spaß gemacht, da mal längerfristig
zu sein, um ein Bild davon zu haben, wie es ist,
in Kalifornien zu wohnen. Auch wenn ich
es persönlich nicht machen wollte,
längerfristig. Es ist eine
weirde Gegend, aber ich meine, die USA
sind generell irgendwie ein bisschen sonderbar.
Bist du ein bisschen rumgefahren? Hast du ein bisschen die Gegend erkundet?
Ich habe auf jeden Fall ein bisschen die Gegend erkundet.
Das weiteste war, dass ich bloß
weitest, in Anführungsstrichen. Ich habe mal auf der Karte
geschaut. Ja, das ist ja nur so
drei Zentimeter
grob, hier mal Daumen nach
L.A. Fahren wir doch mal aus, was
ist ein sechs-Stunden-Trip,
nach L.A. zu fahren. Das war unerwartet weit.
Ja, ja.
Wenn du da Deutschland auf die Karte legst, das...
Ja, also so irgendwie, Deutschland kann nicht so
winzig sein, aber ja doch.
Kennst du The Real Size Of? Ja, ja.
The True Size Of heißt das, glaube ich.
TrueSize.com, genau.
Da kann man jetzt hier mal...
so eine Weltkarte, wo man
Verzerrungen verstehen kann, indem man
da einfach Länder
an eine andere Position auf
Google Maps Basis im Hintergrund zieht. Genau.
Grönland ist nämlich nicht so groß
wie Afrika. Mit Abstand.
Kleiner. Das habe ich hier mal Deutschland eingegeben.
Es ist hier Deutschland so rot geworden und man sieht schon
hier unten auf Afrika liegt das schon so als Default
mal so ganz China, Indien und die USA
oben drauf und das passt übrigens alles in Afrika
rein. Deutschland passt halt locker noch in eine
der vielen Lücken, die da frei sind. Genau, ich schiebe jetzt einfach mal
Deutschland auf Kalifornien.
So, und es passt von Nord
nach Süd komplett drüber.
Das heißt, die
größte Nord-Süd-Portl.
Also du hast noch ein bisschen Platz.
Also Deutschland ist nicht so hoch wie Kalifornien.
Es ist ein bisschen breiter als Kalifornien.
Genau.
Aber ja, also das ist schon kein kleiner Staat.
Genau, wenn ich das jetzt hier reinlege, dann ist
Los Angeles und etwa
an der Grenze zu Österreich tiefstes
Bayern.
San Francisco ist irgendwo bei Frankfurt oder sowas.
Fast im Ruhrpott schon wieder.
Ja, genau.
Cool.
Nimm mich einen Blogpost von Freund des Podcasts, Lukas Woltmann,
der einen witzigen Vergleich gemacht hat.
Ich glaube, er hat es auf Basis der Wikipedia gemacht,
für England und Deutschland,
aus Textkorpussen, wie
über bestimmte Städte gesprochen wird,
mit was für, also
grob gesagt, was für Sprache
benutzt wird, um Städte zu beschreiben und
was für Sprache im Kontext von
diversen Städten ist und hat quasi
eine Karte von England
dann gezeichnet, wo
nur deutsche Städte drauf sind und eine Karte von Deutschland,
wo nur englische Städte drauf sind, jeweils
zu ihrem Äquivalent passend
und da sind halt wirklich super
witzige Parallelen drauf. Also Dresden-Coventry ist
natürlich schon mal ein passendes Beispiel aufgrund von Kriegserstörung.
Die sind ja auch nicht umsonst Partnerstädte.
Eben, eben. Und es sind halt super viele
witzige Parallelen. Also den brauche ich auf jeden Fall
in die Show-Notes mit rein.
Sehr amüsant.
Weil du jetzt gerade bloß halt San Francisco in Europa und L.A.
Mit welcher deutschen Stadt würdest du denn
San Francisco vergleichen?
Schwierig, keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht.
Passt da überhaupt was?
Das ist auch eine Mischung aus Berlin
und Hamburg oder so.
Vielleicht sowas, ja. Also das Coole an San Francisco ist,
dass es halt nicht so eine typisch amerikanische Stadt ist,
die halt einfach nur in die Breite wächst,
wo du nicht, du brauchst, du musst ein Auto haben, um irgendwo hinzukommen.
Es geht ja dort auch nicht wirklich.
Eben, die Stadt kann halt geografisch bedingt nicht von ihrer Halbnisel runter
und wächst dann halt mehr zusammen und in die Höhe und so Kram halt,
aber nicht wirklich auseinander.
Dadurch hast du halt auch viel auf engstem Raum, was super cool ist.
Da ist auch immer wirklich was los.
Aber in anderen amerikanischen Großstädten ist halt einfach,
ja, hier ist halt jetzt nichts.
Da ist eine Strip-Mall, dann fährst du eine halbe Stunde in die Richtung,
da ist noch eine Strip-Mall, cool.
Ich hatte das Problem in amerikanischen Städten,
dass ich die Schwierigkeit habe, die als Städte anzuerkennen,
weil die sich alle anfühlen wie so Einkaufsvorort von so Städten.
Das ist wirklich wahr.
Ja, also es ist alles so ein bisschen wie Elbe Park.
Und dann ist alles super flach, auch je nachdem, in welcher Gegend du bist.
Ich war nicht wirklich, also die waren selten irgendwie höher als zwei Stockwerke.
Das ist echt super selten, das stimmt schon.
Weil sie halt viel Platz haben.
Witzigerweise diese ganzen kleinen amerikanischen Einfamilienhäuser sind auch super flach.
Wenn du da davor stehst, dann denkst du, wenn du reingehst, stößt dir den Kopf oder so.
Okay.
Ja, und alles in allem ist es sehr autolastig.
Sehr. Also die Straßen sind ja krass.
Also dieses deutsche Feeling von wegen, ich renne mal schnell über die Straße zum Bäcker.
Okay, ich komme ja aus meinem Haus raus und da ist eine vierspurige Straße
und die Ampel für Fußgänger braucht halt erstmal fünf Minuten, um zu schalten.
Das ist halt bescheuert.
Also das hat mir persönlich überhaupt nicht gefallen, wie autolastig das wirklich ist.
Ich meine, ich kenne die USA, ich habe da schon mal gewohnt,
aber das war in Ohio, das war halt
gefühlt nochmal anderes, weil wir da in wirklich
in Columbus, Ohio, in so einem
Stadtteil gewohnt haben, der ein bisschen mehr
Fußgängerfreundlich war, würde ich behaupten.
Auch kinderfreundlich eher.
Aber gerade die Bay Area ist ja
und andere Teile der USA
sind halt unglaublich
autolastig. Unglaublichst.
Sehr hart.
Beziehungsweise die Bay Area ist sehr Tesla-lastig.
Das ist auch sehr witzig.
Es ist schon cool, wenn jedes dritte Auto Tesla ist.
und Tesla-Out-Air-Fahrer müssen ja anscheinend,
da gibt es ja irgendwie gesetzliche Grundlage
für, dass sie sich ein Vanity-Plate
setzen, wo irgendeine Anspielung zu
Elon Musk drauf ist. Echt, ja?
Was hat er gesehen? Also ich meine, der
Klassiker Thanks Elon oder divers anderes,
ein Kumpel Ben hat letztens
ein Bild geschickt mit seinem Favorit,
was auch der beste wirklich
bisher ist, das war ein Tesla mit dem Kennzeichen,
wo drauf stand, keine, also wirklich auf Deutsch
keine, dann ein Symbol für eine Hand
und da hinten eh also keine Hände, Hands-Free
Autopilot, war wohl der Witz dahinter.
Keine Hände, das ist ein super Kennzeichen.
Klasse.
Wie haben sie die Hände gemacht?
Du kannst auch Symbole mit draufpacken, so ein Herz oder eine Hand
oder ein Stern, das geht auch.
Ich glaube, es gibt
ein Limit für wie viele.
In welchem Land konnte man jetzt Emoji-License-Player
machen? Das ist nicht mehr weit entfernt.
Cool.
Da geht schon einiges.
Ich glaube,
Eiherz-Tacos,
das habe ich auch gesehen, den fand ich auch toll.
Obwohl sie angeblich mit dem Liefern gar nicht
mal so sehr hinterherkommen. Es muss so ein bisschen sein,
wie wenn man ein Trabi bestellt, dass man mehrere Monate
warten muss, bis man dann sein Tesla war.
15 Jahre für dein Model S.
Bis dann gibt es den schon
gar nicht mehr. Stimmt.
Da ist Tesla schon wieder pleite.
Da kriegst du ein Space-Hype geliefert.
Ja, also als ich in den USA gelebt habe,
habe ich in so einem Sub-Airb gelebt, was sich
so schön organisch von oben aussieht,
weil es alles so verschlungen ist.
Ja, das ist so Schwammmuster.
Also wirklich typischer Suburbia-Verschnitt?
Ja, genau.
Und da war es halt so, dass es nicht mal Fußwege gab.
Du bist entweder auf der Straße oder auf jemandem das Rasen gelaufen.
Und wir hatten Freunde, die haben irgendwie 300 Meter hingewohnt.
Die sind mit dem Auto gekommen, wenn sie uns besucht haben.
Ja, sehr klar.
Weil es einfach nicht vorgesehen ist, dass man sich irgendwie zwischen zwei Grundstücken nicht mit dem Auto bewegt.
Das ist schon eigenartig.
Also es fühlt sich so falsch an, wenn du aus Europa kommst, finde ich.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Vielleicht hat der Fokus schon ganz anders.
Viele Kollegen von mir, die in Santa Barbara arbeiten,
die fahren auch trotzdem jeden Tag mit dem Fahrrad.
Du kannst es halt auch machen,
aber Fahrradfahren fühlt sich halt auf fünfspurig.
Also fünfspurig meine ich jetzt eine Seite, nicht komplett.
Also zehnspurigen Straßen insgesamt.
Fühlt sich halt an wie Selbstmord.
Vor allem, wenn du halt ganz rechts fährst, weil du das so gewohnt bist.
Und dann willst du links abbiegen und musst einmal über fünf Spuren kreuzen.
Da fällt mir eine Kulturempfehlung ein
vor kurzem lief hier im Kino
im Kasten und man kann es eventuell noch
irgendwo anders auf Streamingdiensten
schauen, eine schöne Doku, ist auch schon
zwei, drei Jahre älter, Bikes vs. Cars
Okay, sag mir nichts. Und da geht es
allgemein darum, wie zum Beispiel
Los Angeles war mal die größte
Fahrradfahrerstadt der Welt. Achso. Die hatten
extra so Schnellstraßen für
Fahrräder. Ach nee, die hatten
auf jeden Fall Schnellstraßen für Fahrräder, aber sie waren mal die
größte ÖPNV-Netz mit Straßenbahnen
und allem möglichen. Und dann gab es halt diese Geschichte,
dass das von Chrysler oder Ford...
Ich glaube, ich dachte, GM hing da irgendwie...
GM hat es gekauft und hat es der Reihe nach verschrottet
und hat den Leuten gesagt, hier, kauft unsere Autos.
Und dann haben sie gemerkt, oh, es fahren mehr Autos,
fahren mehr Leute Auto, die Straße ist ständig verstopft,
machen wir noch eine Spur mehr.
Wir müssen es schon wieder verstopfen, machen wir noch eine Spur mehr.
Und so ist es halt in L.A. eskaliert.
Und die Stadt ist total autofasifisch.
Aber diese Stadt ist so gigantisch.
Das ist hart.
Möchte ich jetzt nicht zu viel vorwegnehmen.
Habe ich mir neulich mit Freunden zusammen angeguckt.
Alles auch so verpflichtende Fahrradfahrer.
Sehr gute Doku Bikes vs. Cars.
Ich habe es mal in die Show Notes mit reingenommen.
Sehr gut.
Verlinkt noch.
Ja, krass.
Jetzt haben wir ja schon eine ganze Menge über
dich und dein Praktikum geredet.
Gibt es noch irgendwas, was man erwähnen könnte?
Du meinst, was so allgemein passiert ist
im letzten halben Jahr?
Was ist noch so alles passiert mit dir?
Was ich so ein bisschen verpasst habe, was hier so mit passiert ist,
ist diese ganze Artikel 13 Geschichte.
Das stimmt.
Ich war zumindest bei einer Demo mit dabei
und habe geschrien, dass ich kein Bot sei.
Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Wie kommst du auf
dieser...
Der Witz ist jetzt...
Ab jetzt kannst du nur noch hier reinwenden
und Capture lösen.
So die Tür kleben.
Ah, Klingelschild als Capture.
Der Terminator.
Ja, perfekt.
Geil.
Und der arme Postbote.
Bitte erkennen Sie hier die
Straßenschilder auf diesem Foto.
Achso, du hast ein beschissenes
Google Capture, was du immer lösen musst,
noch richtig interaktiv.
Gab es da nicht irgendwas, das haben wir vielleicht schon mal erwähnt,
wo jemand
diese Sprachcaptures
einfach an einen anderen Google-Dienst gepipt hat?
Ja, ja, ja.
Gut, okay. Also zumindest es gab
Artikel 13 Demonstrationen und
mittlerweile haben wir in Europa ein neues Urheberrecht.
Cool.
Ja, also ein paar von den Sachen
in dem neuen Urheberrecht
sind ja ganz sinnvoll. Ich verweise an dieser
Stelle einfach an Logbuch und Netzpolitik, weil
die Intention dahinter ist ja richtig,
aber die Umsetzung ist halt Bullshit.
Gab es diesen einen Typen von der CDU,
der gesagt hat, ich setze mir jetzt diese
Kappe auf und peitsche das durch
und der hat das
Internet kaputt gemacht. Wie ist der?
Was ich halt sehr beschreibend fand auch
oder was halt beschreibend sehr
interessant war dieser Post von
Fefe, dass die
CDU sicherlich
Experten gefragt hat, können wir
davon ausgehen, dass sie sicherlich zu einer Firma wie
T-Systems hingegangen sind und gefragt hat, kann man das so umsetzen?
Und als ob T-Systems
den Mann mit dem Geldkoffer nach Hause schickt,
natürlich sagen die, klar ist das drin.
Und dann denkt sich ein CDU-Politiker
natürlich auch klar, ich meine, wenn die Experten sagen, das geht,
was wollen diese Idioten auf der Straße denn
sagen? Die haben doch keine Ahnung, die Experten haben wir gesagt.
Das sind alles 15-Jährige, die haben keine Ahnung.
Ich kann es auch irgendwo verstehen,
dass du dich dann bestätigt fühlst.
Wenn die Leute aus der Industrie behaupten, das geht,
dann geht das natürlich auch.
Aber wenn die Leute in der Industrie einfach,
ja, ich nehme mir einen Stapel Geld und schauen wir mal,
wie wir das machen, das wird halt schon irgendwie gehen,
nur noch nicht gut.
Du kannst natürlich als Politiker,
es ist auch wirklich,
als Politiker bist du ja nicht gefordert,
dass du alles weißt und alles kannst.
Das ist ja auch richtig so.
Und du sollst natürlich,
und es ist auch schön, wenn du siehst,
mal in den USA Leute
von Tech-Firmen irgendwie plötzlich
so als Consultants herangezogen werden, bei
irgendwelchen wichtigen Entscheidungen.
Die Telekom oder andere so,
ja,
es ist halt schwierig, wen du fragst,
Firmen, die an der
in diesem Ding, wie nennt man das,
ein berechtigtes wirtschaftliches
Interesse haben, dass bestimmte Entscheidungen getroffen
werden. Die sollte man dafür vielleicht
nicht unbedingt... Sollte man vielleicht
mehrere Meinungen einholen.
Aber es ist natürlich mehr Aufwand.
Es wird mich mal interessieren, wie solche Entscheidungen
eigentlich wirklich gefällt werden. Wir müssen mal
Julia Reda ändern. Oh, das ist ja eine coole Folge.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben ja schon Überlappungen mit den Gästen
von Logbuch-Netzpolitik gehabt.
Sollen wir mit Anna gesprochen haben,
oder was?
Aber gut, okay.
Das bloß aus der Neuigkeiten-Sektion
die richtigen
Hintergründe und Fakten.
Wie gesagt, ich empfehle Logbuch-Netzpolitik
die letzten 10 Folgen.
Ich kann auch nicht quer durchhören.
Ich saß heute früh bei Freunden
beim Brunch und wir haben noch so ein bisschen
über dies und jenes erzählt und da ging es um
WikiLeaks und einer von uns
vier, die wir da saßen, auch Softwareentwickler,
hat gesagt,
gibt es den Assange eigentlich noch?
Was ist denn aus dem geworden?
Du hast gehört, dass der neulich
aus der Botschaft
rausgeflogen ist und jetzt irgendwie
in Haft sitzt oder in Untersuchungshaft
sitzt. Achso?
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, ja, Julio Assange
und alle, der ist immer so gekichert und der eine hat
Achso, kann ich noch gar nicht den Namen.
Was, Julio?
Du hörst offenbar auch kein Logbuch-Netzpolitik.
Ich höre das mit Monaten Verzögerung,
weil ich einfach mal mein Podcast...
Die nennen den schon seit Jahren Julio Ascens, seitdem der
äquatorianischen Buchstaben... Achso, aha, der Witz, okay.
Ja, gut.
Verdammt.
So, bei mir lädt unsere Seite
wirklich immer noch nicht. Das ist ja eigenartig.
Bei mir lädt sie. Ich mach mal
meinen Arbeitsbrowser auf, nämlich Chrome.
Ja, ach.
Und zwar in Chromium.
Da ist ja weniger Google Food drin.
Ach, da ist er.
Schauen wir nochmal ins Hack-MD.
Was ist denn noch so passiert
im letzten halben Jahr?
Ich habe mir hin und wieder mal
Dinge notiert, dass irgendwann gekauft wurde.
Was heißt hin und wieder mal?
Es war einmal und dann noch mal zwei Tage.
Akronomisierbar gehört jetzt der Mieterebene.
Was?
Hart.
Für wie viel haben wir uns
auf den Tisch?
Für
20 Daueraufträge.
Der Pritlov hatte
bis zu über 1000
da ein paar abgegeben.
Okay.
Das Einzige, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe, wurde, glaube ich,
dass das Nginx, äh, Nginx oder Nginx,
wie man es nennen möchte, gekauft wurde.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt schon in die Hose gegangen ist. Ich glaube, das dauert
noch ein halbes Jahr, dann geht es in die Hose.
Der Kauf oder Nginx selber?
Ja, beides, je nachdem. Also, sag immer, hier,
Das tolle Projekt geht weiter und mal schauen, bis wann das
nicht mehr der Fall ist. Wer hat das gekauft?
F5 heißen die.
Ich dachte, das wäre ein Typo gewesen.
Nee.
Okay, F5, also so
Reload-Seite. Ja, genau.
Genau sowas. Ich kannte die vorher nicht.
Ich habe aber jetzt nicht viel reingeschaut.
Ich weiß, dass die da mal weggegangen sind.
Das andere war jetzt vor ein paar Tagen.
War das Realm.
Realm, Realm, Realm, Realm.
Ich mag den Namen einfach auszusprechen.
gekauft wurden von MongoDB, interessanterweise.
Das war so eine coole, mobile, embedded
kleine Datenbank.
Ich habe die unter iOS ja gerne mal
benutzt.
Sehr cool, technisch dahergekommen.
War auch mal zur WWDC 2016
damals bei denen im Ad-Quarter.
Die waren exakt neben dem Docker-Büro
in San Francisco, fand ich cool.
Coole Leute auch, die dort waren,
die teilweise immer noch sind.
Beziehungsweise, keine Ahnung, wie es jetzt ausschaut.
Aber ich finde es schade, dass MongoDB
gekauft hat, weil von Mongo halte ich
hielt ich noch nicht viel, vielleicht ist das eine
nicht sehr gerechtfertigte Meinung.
MongoDB ist auch so ein bisschen
ein Schimpfwort, oder?
Das halt auch.
Das heißt,
es gab mal irgendwas, was irgendwie Daten verloren
hatte bei irgendwas
und da wurde dann
der Witz gemacht, das ist das MongoDB,
der so und so.
Die haben halt schon
vieles falsch gemacht, sagen wir es so.
Es klappt wunderbar,
NoSQL-Datenbank, aber
die machen halt
immer wieder Schrott. Und das sind immer wieder
dieselben Probleme, von wegen unserer Authentication
ist kaputt, deswegen sind hier 10.000 Instanzen
aus Versehen öffentlich zugänglich,
die irgendwo laufen.
Es ist immer wieder derselbe Schruz, der bei denen gegen die Wand
läuft. War das nicht ein Problem von
Redis? Das ist auch so ein typisches
Redis-Problem, was mich persönlich
damals gebissen hat, wo mein Server
plötzlich hacked by Iranian Cyber
Army dastand oder so ein Kram.
bei Redis nur lief,
das ist mir tierisch auch nicht kurz damals,
dass ich halt ein Issue auch gemacht habe von wegen
hier, warum läuft das denn, wenn ich es nur installiere
mit Standard-Auth-Details auf dem
Standard-Port komplett offen und
ich kann damit darüber Road-Execution machen und
der Maintainer hat das Issue halt geschlossen mit
Ja, works as intended.
Mann,
das ist doch scheiße, aber
kann das nicht einfach mal
nicht per Default nach...
Ja, aber kann das nicht mal nicht per Default nach außen
in Offenseite, das kann doch nur
abused werden.
Das hat mich einfach gestört damals, aber seitdem nutze ich halt
kein Vendels mehr.
Das ist aber auch wieder ein paar Jahre her.
Also NGX gibt's noch
und das war...
Das wäre halt auch fatal, wenn es das nicht mehr gibt.
Das ist eine russische Firma, soweit ich mich richtig erinnere.
Die gehören jetzt F5 Networks.
Was ist denn F5?
Ich meine, das ist ein cooler Name für Networking-Poo.
Ah, Neuladen, Neuladen, Neuladen.
Ach, das kommt mir ja wie bekannt vor.
Das Logo sieht ein bisschen aus wie das von der Zigarettenmarke.
Ja.
Achso, das andere ist F6.
I see.
Okay.
Oh Mann.
Naja, manchmal ist ja so ein
Acquiry gar nicht mal so schlimm.
Das heißt, die andere Firma
hat ein Interesse daran, dass es weitergeht.
So kann es natürlich kommen.
So muss es auch nicht kommen, aber du kannst es kommen.
Ja, also manchmal wirst du halt von Oracle gekauft
und zugemacht.
manchmal wirst du halt wie GitHub
von Microsoft gekauft
und sehen bislang eigentlich
nicht, dass das irgendwelche Nachteile, oder?
Haben wir da irgendwas mitbekommen? Naja, keine öffentlichen
Nachteile, ich habe halt keine Ahnung, was...
Ich finde es immer noch unschön,
dass Microsoft theoretisch Zugang zu allen
privaten Repos hat.
Ich meine, da kann man davon halten, was
man möchte. Davor war es
GitHub, die da Zugang hatten, jetzt ist es eine andere Firma,
eine Firma, die ich... Ja, aber ich meine,
so ein GitHub-Repo, selbst wenn es privat ist, ist ja
nichts, wo du jetzt irgendwelche... Ne, sollst du
Auf keinen Fall, ganz klar.
Aber es ist halt trotzdem fragwürdig,
wenn halt Microsoft Zugang zu möglichen Competitors hat,
die ihre Infrastruktur auf GitHub bringen.
Ja, gut, okay, aber das gilt ja dann quasi auch für Amazon und für Google.
Absolut, klar.
Also das Argument geht auch weiter.
Aber vorher war es halt GitHub und dann wurde,
ohne dass du was dagegen tun konntest als Kunde,
hat halt plötzlich Microsoft die Finger drin.
Du hast aber hoffentlich immer noch die gleichen hier SLAs,
also Service Level Agreements mit Microsoft dann halt.
Das heißt, wenn die auf deine Sachen zugreifen,
kannst du wahrscheinlich mit dem gleichen
rechtlichen Hintergrundflug nagen.
Das weißt du aber halt nicht mal wirklich.
Ich meine, Microsoft ist hoffentlich
ein bisschen ehrlicher unterwegs als Facebook,
die halt wirklich da einfach Bullshit machen.
Ah nee, Amazon war das ja letztens,
die sich in internen Chaträumen lustige Alexa-Recordings
einfach hin und her schicken, die Mitarbeiter.
Oh.
Das ist halt cool.
Ich meine, auch wenn du als Kunde
das okay findest,
dass Amazon halt Recordings von dir speichert,
für immer,
von deiner Alexa-Interaktion und möglicherweise
gar nicht mal Interaktion, weil das Ding einfach alleine angegangen ist
oder wer weiß, was sie da abhören.
Das muss einmal dahingestellt.
Aber auch wenn das für dich in Ordnung ist,
dann musst du halt auch irgendwo
die Informationen mitbekommen,
dass Mitarbeiter das halt auch einfach
in internen Slack-Räumen hin- und herschicken.
Das ist vor allem...
Das weißt du nicht und das ist halt alles andere als okay.
Das ist vor allem was,
was schon einen gewissen Punkt überschreitet.
Also, dass diese Daten vorgehalten werden
und vielleicht irgendwie zum Debugging
oder zur
Qualitätssicherung genutzt werden, ist
eine Sache. Oder um
dein Profil zu verbessern.
Was ich ja schon an sich gruselig finde.
Aber diese Daten soll definitiv nicht von
Mitarbeitern direkt zugegriffen werden.
Irgendwer muss ja darauf zugreifen, damit du die nutzen
kannst. Aber dass sie halt Dinge
amüsant finden und rumschicken
beziehungsweise da halt wirklich
Recordings haben, die halt so fragwürdig sind,
weil da halt du mithörst
und beweisen kannst, dass halt irgendwie
Crime passiert ist. Und die halt nicht
darauf agieren, weil das natürlich nicht die Aufgabe von Amazon
ist. Aber es ist halt auch
fragwürdig. Sollten sie, sollten sie nicht.
Oder beziehungsweise, wenn die halt einfach Dinge hören, die lustig
sind, weil sie jemandem beim Sex zugehört haben, keine Ahnung.
Und das halt einfach teilen.
Das geht halt so überhaupt gar nicht.
Hoffentlich, also
ich meine, was heißt hoffentlich, jeder kann machen, was er möchte,
aber wenn du jetzt Alexa-phil bist,
Alexophil,
Objektophil.
Das geht jetzt, glaube ich, zu weit.
Du hast angefangen damit.
Ne, was ich schlimm finde, ist, dass ja wirklich Menschen,
also das Ding bei
Google heißt Google oder
Okay Google oder Hey Google.
Sowas, ja. Siri ist
auch nicht so ein häufiger, eher
künstlicher Name, aber es gibt halt
sehr viele Leute, die Alexa heißen.
Deswegen kannst du das Ding ja immer unbedingt auf Hey Computer
sagen. Ja, aber Computer, gut
Computer ist fast witzig, bis du merkst, dass du relativ
häufig Computer in einem anderen Kontext sagst.
Aber
so eine Art Sklavenname
geworden.
Stimmt, du kannst dein Kind jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr Alexa nennen.
Wenn du jetzt in dem Kontext in dem Wissen deiner Tochter
Alexa nennst, ist ein bisschen weird.
Es gibt Leute, die nennen ihre Kinder Siri und Cortana.
Google ist glaube ich weird,
wenn du dein Kind Google nennst, aber
ich meine die anderen Sachen, also Siri, Cortana
und Alexa sind halt irgendwo Namen, wenn auch
sehr weirde Namen,
wenn du das deinen Kindern so gibst.
Siehst du hier einen Nachbarn
von mir? Die geht schon hier auf den Balkon und
macht irgendwas in die Pflanzen und es kommt im Augenwinkel,
dass da irgendwer rauskommt.
Ich habe dieses Fenster fast nie offen, weil mir da Leute
reingucken können, die ja direkt gegenüber sind.
Aber ich dachte, wo wir jetzt mal hier sitzen,
muss ich mal ein Radieschen geholt.
Ach, Radieschen?
Ja.
Ach, ich brauche eine Angel.
Kommt bestimmt auch gut.
Ja.
Was ist denn sonst so in der letzten Zeit passiert?
Ich meine, ich habe auch ein paar andere Sachen gemacht,
aber ich fühle mich das jetzt in dieser Folge
gar nicht so sehr in den Mittelpunkt rücken.
Aber du hast einen coolen Talk gehalten letztens.
Genau, ich habe es endlich mal geschafft.
Wir haben bei uns in der Firma auch so einen Slot,
wo wir uns gegenseitig so Tech Talks halten.
Das sind auch immer sehr interessante Sachen dabei.
Ich will immer Tech Talks.
Tech Talks.
Das heißt bei uns Tech Talk.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe den Begriff Tech Talk
vorher auch noch nie so gehört.
Kein Tech Talk?
Nee, Vorträge.
Und da hatte ich mir schon das gesamte letzte Jahr vorgenommen,
mal einen Vortrag über WebAssembly zu halten.
Dann habe ich es immer von mir hergeschoben.
Und dann ist es nie geschafft.
Ich wollte vorher mal wirklich was damit gebaut haben
und
weil
der Stack noch nicht wirklich
ausgeprägt wurde, dass es irgendwie viel zu zeigen gab.
Also man konnte halt zeigen, okay, ich kann jetzt hier
dieses C++ oder dieses Rust nach WebAssembly
kompilieren und den Browser ausführen
und man sieht dann halt das, was auf der Konsole geprintet
wird und die ganzen Leute, die krassere Beispiele gebaut
haben, haben halt Tage und Wochen
Arbeitszeit reingesteckt.
Das wollte ich einfach nicht investieren und dann wurde es irgendwann
machbarer und dann kamen
diese ganzen coolen Rust-Wise-
Binding Generator-Geschichten raus.
Da habe ich bei irgendeinem
Game Jam mit Gilbert zusammen
mal ein Spiel gebaut damit. Ach, das war ein Game Jam-Projekt?
Das war ein Game Jam-Projekt. Alle haben irgendwas mit Unity
gebaut und übelst krasse Sachen abgeliefert und wir
dachten, wir nutzen das mal als
Slot für so eine Tech-Demo.
Ja, um sowas mal zu machen. Genau, wir haben uns also
eine Physik-Engine, die in Rust geschrieben ist,
genommen und damit halt so ein 2D
Gorillas-Klon
gebaut, wo die Gebäude wirklich aus
Ziegelsteinen, die sich frei bewegen können,
zusammengesetzt worden und du kannst halt
mit Bananen unterschiedlichen Gewichts
aufeinander schießen. Unterschiedlichen Gewichts?
Ja, ja. Manche explodieren auch
und dann fliegen halt die Ziegelsteine
weg und das ist eigentlich schon ganz cool. Das kann ich leider nicht
wirklich zeigen, weil ich diese Playstation-Controller
mit denen wir das gemacht haben nicht besitze.
Irgendwann wir einen Podcast aufnehmen, wo man die nicht zeigen kann.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich kann da nochmal genauer, also bei der
nächsten Folge nochmal genauer drüber reden.
Und da hab ich... Aber es ist auch online. Kann man das verlinken?
Meine Slides?
Nee, das Gorilla-Spiel.
Ja, das ist einfach auch...
wenn ihr Playstation-Controller auf einem
Chrome habt, ich glaube,
diese Controller-API ist einfach
nicht vorhersehbar. Da gibt es bestimmt irgendeine
Lib, die irgendwie das
vereinheitlicht, dass du immer weißt,
das ist jetzt X und das ist jetzt Quadrat.
Weil unterschiedliche Kontrollen unterschiedliche Webinarien schicken.
Genau. Auch diese Joysticks, die du hast,
die sind bei manchen wirklich
analog und bei manchen diskret.
Okay. Und wir haben es halt
aus Zeitgründen nur
in Chrome mit
Playstation-Controllern gebaut.
Man muss sich auch limitieren auf irgendwas, was sinnvoll ist.
Also wenn ihr das habt, dann könnt ihr auf
naubino.de slash
awsm-gorillas. Das sind die Show Notes.
Genau, wir packen das in die Show Notes.
Und naubino.de ist dieses andere Spiel, was wir da
vor Jahren mal mit CoffeeScript gebaut haben,
was wir irgendwann nochmal neu bauen wollten.
Anyway, den Vortrag habe ich dann neulich
auf einem JavaScript
Meetup in Dresden nochmal
gehalten. Das war auch
ein ganz schön langer Vortrag, weil dieser
Talk-Slot bei uns auf Arbeit ist immer eine Stunde.
Also habe ich für eine Stunde Talk gemacht.
Ne, war aber auch ein sehr cooler Talk, sehr formativ.
Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also hast du auch generell mal so Hintergründe von Wasim mit Ausgleichen, wie das genau alles funktioniert.
Wenn du nicht mehr in der Uni bist und dann einfach mal so ein bisschen Forschung,
das war ja quasi so eine Art Seminararbeit, ich hab da schon ein paar Stunden rein versenkt in dieses Teil.
Ich würde das auch gerne nochmal irgendwo halten, es gibt ja noch hier andere Web-Meetups in Dresden,
das könnte ich nochmal recyceln.
Zumindest bin ich zu dem Organisator von dem JavaScript-Meetup hier in Dresden hingegangen
gesagt. Achso, hast du vorher auch
nicht drin? Ich war da ein paar Mal zu Besuch.
Achso, okay. Der eine Typ
halt halt, der das organisiert halt meistens einen Talk
und dann immer auch mich anderen Gäste,
aber es geht meistens, das ist sehr Frontend-lastig,
da geht es hauptsächlich um
React versus Vue und
das
interessiert mich da meistens auch nicht, deswegen bin ich nicht häufig
da, aber ich bin
zu dem hin und hab gesagt, ich hab hier diesen Tag-Talk,
könnte ich mal,
könnte ich den vielleicht bei euch halten, bloß aus Interesse?
Ja, gerne, zeigt mal her.
ja, war ganz gut.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Genau, und in dem Rahmen
habe ich damit rumgespielt. Es sind ja sehr viele Sachen in letzter Zeit
passiert, dass
WebAssembly hat sich ja
doch schon eher
so als Ersatz für einige
andere Kerntechnologien
angeboten in letzter Zeit. Also
es gab Leute zum Beispiel,
oder einer der Entwickler von Docker,
die gesagt haben, wenn es vor 10 Jahren schon
WebAssembly gegeben hätte,
dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich gar kein Docker gebaut.
sowas. Das Quote finde ich
immer noch sehr spannend. Ich habe es
nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden.
Die Idee dahinter ist, dass das Security Model
in dieselbe Richtung geht
und Wasm sehr
wie sage ich das am besten?
Du kannst halt nicht einfach
random Sachen anfassen
von außerhalb.
Was ich als Kontext, ja genau.
Was ist, Wasm
oder WebAssembly läuft ja in so einer
läuft im gleichen Kontext wie JavaScript,
in deiner JavaScript VM
und wird vom JavaScript JIT-Compiler
einfach zu nativem Maschinencode gemacht
und läuft dann
dementsprechend schnell.
Das läuft trotzdem über JavaScript.
Aber es läuft trotzdem innerhalb von dem JavaScript-Kontext
und du kannst damit nichts machen, was du nicht mit JavaScript machen kannst.
JavaScript, JavaScript.
Und wenn du
das Security oder Isolation Model
ist quasi, wenn du was außen machen möchtest,
selbst wenn du es im Browser machst, wenn du zum Beispiel
das Alert, die Alert-Funktion
aufrufen möchtest oder was in die Konsole schreiben
möchtest, musst du dazu immer erst
so eine Capability reinreichen. Das heißt, du hast
irgendwie, initialisierst dein
Reson-Modul mit so einem Import-Objekt
und da kannst du einfach ein Objekt,
ein JavaScript-Objekt, und da kannst
du Function-Pointer reingeben, die du dann aufrufen
kannst. Von innen,
die musst du dann teilweise noch rappen, weil
unterschiedliche Sachen mit, jetzt spule ich das alles runter,
weil du kannst
zum Beispiel nicht aus Rust raus einen String nach
JavaScript geben,
den musst du eventuell umcodieren, weil die einen
UTF-8, die anderen UTF-16 und
möchte ich den kopieren oder möchte ich
eine Referenz rausgeben und so. Das sind so Sachen, über die
du plötzlich Gedanken machen musst.
Und jetzt gibt's halt schon
so Node.js-artige
Runtimes für WebAssembly-Binaries.
Ein Beispiel zum Beispiel war von Wasmur, dass
sie Nginx nach WebAssembly kopiliert haben und
dann konntest du plötzlich Nginx.wasm
in diesem Dings ausführen.
Und das Schöne ist halt,
das läuft halt nicht als
nativer x86-Code auf deiner Kiste
und kann dementsprechend auch nicht einfach
Syscalls machen, die werden auch nicht einfach alle
reingereicht oder sowas
und dadurch
würden
so bestimmte Aufrufe wie ich mach mal
eine Datei auf oder ich
mach mal einen Websocket, einen Socket auf,
Networksocket auf, würden dann einfach scheitern.
Das heißt, du musst dann
schauen, aha, ich linke,
du musst irgendwie diese Syscalls
abstrahieren und reingeben und
deinem WebAssembly-Code so eine Art
Objekt geben, was dann an dieser Stelle
auf diese API zugreift.
Verstehe. Ein schöner
Introduction Talk, bevor ich hier anfange
zu stammeln, ist vom 32C3.
Da hat der Macher von
CloudABI über
was ähnliches geredet. Der hat eine schöne
Analogie gefunden.
Wenn du normalen Code schreibst,
kannst du natürlich in deinem Code einfach
sagen, ich mache jetzt hier das auf und ich mache jetzt hier das auf
innerhalb einer Funktion. Du kannst allerdings
auch sagen,
wenn ich es jetzt testbar machen möchte, dann würde ich
diese ganzen Abhängigkeiten ja nicht da drin
erzeugen, sondern von außen reingeben.
Dadurch könnte ich zum Beispiel Mox reingeben und das testbar machen.
Warum machen wir das nicht eigentlich auch für komplette Binary so?
Warum kann jeder Binary ihre eigenen Dateien aufmachen
oder ihre eigenen Network-Sockets aufmachen oder ihren eigenen Speicher allokieren?
Könnte man doch auch beim Starten von außen reingeben.
Und wenn du solche Garantien haben kannst,
dann fallen halt einige Use Cases für Docker zum Beispiel weg.
Wenn du sagen kannst, ich habe jetzt hier einen Docker-Container
und den habe ich nur, weil da drin ein Nginx läuft,
und ich möchte, dass das das und das nicht macht,
aber Nginx erwartet halt, dass es auf einem Linux
nativ läuft, möchte ich dem aber nicht
geben.
Naja, was ist denn, wenn du jetzt einen Server hast, der einfach eine
Resim-Binary ist
und du weißt genau, welchen
Zocker die aufmacht und in welche Log-Datei die
schreibt und welchen Ordner das surft.
Das ist schon sehr wohl definiert, was du da...
Das ist quasi eine wohl definierte API für so ein...
Das ist echt chic, das gefällt mir auch.
Oder
ein ganz anderes Beispiel,
Node.js Extensions.
warum zum Gaia habe ich native
Node.js Extensions, also dass ich irgendwas
in C++ schreibe,
rappe und dann von Node laden lasse als Modul,
weil es performant ist
oder weil ich damit vielleicht Sachen machen kann, für die
Node.js noch keine API anbietet.
Wenn es bloß um die Performance geht
oder darum, dass ich irgendwas mache, was in C++
geschrieben ist oder in Rust geschrieben ist,
warum muss ich das heute noch
nach
zu einem Node-Add-on machen?
Warum gebe ich das nicht?
Vor allem, weil man es lokal noch
kompilieren muss. Du gehst jetzt
zum Beispiel,
ein schönes Beispiel ist sowas wie
Nogugiri oder sowas.
Du hast eine Extension für, das ist jetzt
im Ruby-Kontext, aber du hast irgendeinen
nativen XML-Parser oder irgendeinen
nativen irgendwas-Parser, den deine
JavaScript-Geschichte braucht.
Momentan ist es so, wenn ich mir
das installiere mit Node, dann kommt halt nach dem
Node-Install so ein Post-Install-Skript,
der dann irgendwie schaut, oh, was für eine Compiler
liegen denn hier rum?
Du musst übrigens einen C++ und einen GCC
oder einen Clang und einen Compiler darlegen haben,
sonst geht dieses JavaScript-Dings nicht,
weil es dir nach dem Installieren plötzlich
diesen Batzen C kompiliert
und dann steht in deinem
NPM-Block compiling this
so und so und dann erst kann
das eine bestimmte Funktion erfüllen.
Und auch übrigens, das ist alles
nicht innerhalb von dem Node-Kontext, ergo
das könnte jetzt Sachen machen,
über die du keine Kontrolle hast.
Was ist denn, wenn du sowas einfach
als vorkompiliertes WebAssembly mitlieferst?
du kannst den gleichen C++-Code nehmen, der
dein XML parsst, du legst es einfach
als Wismit dazu, du musst es vor Ort nicht mehr
kompilieren, weil es WebAssembly ist
das wird halt vom JIT-Compiler nochmal
nachkompiliert, das musst du immer, weil du
nicht weißt, auf welche Architektur du laufen wirst
und du kannst diesem
XML-Parser sagen
du darfst
übrigens nur die Datei, die ich dir
reingebe, parsen und du darfst
bitte nur in diese Datei die
ISDX schreiben, so, das würde
zum Beispiel dieses ganze
Typo-Squatting-Szenario,
dass sich Leute
oder
war das dieses
Typo-Squatting?
Dass Leute beim Installieren von
Node-Dependencies dein End lesen
und an irgendeinen Rest-Endpoint schicken.
Das würde dann gar nicht mehr gehen,
weil das End gibt es dann natürlich gar nicht.
Das ist richtig geil.
Das habe ich schon mal nachgedacht.
Genau, und das habe ich
so mal angesprochen, mal kurz in meinem
ist ein Riesenthema, also du fängst an mit
übrigens, das ist
JavaScript, warum ist JavaScript langsam?
Ach übrigens, es gibt den JIT-Compiler, ach übrigens,
man kann da andere Sprachen hin kompilieren,
ach übrigens, jetzt gibt es übrigens Compiler und andere Sprachen,
was gibt es denn so für Sprachen, die dann kompilieren können?
Was kann man damit im Browser machen?
Ach übrigens, es gibt nicht nur einen Browser, wo JavaScript läuft,
ach übrigens, man braucht nicht unbedingt eine
JavaScript-Umgebung, es gibt auch
von irgendwelchen, von Cloudflare
oder so zum Beispiel,
gibt es irgendwelche,
gibt es WebAssembly, Runtimes,
die überhaupt nichts mit JavaScript zu tun haben
die fangen halt schon mit solchen Sachen an
aber wie cool, das wusste ich auch nicht
und so hast du natürlich
wenn du das alles beleuchten willst in einem Talk
wo die Leute vorher vielleicht
nur JavaScript mal gehört haben und noch nie was von Web
das natürlich, eigentlich ist das irgendwie eine Vorlesungsreihe
über 5 Vorlesungen
oder so, wenn du das gründlich machen willst
ja und das habe ich irgendwie
das habe ich alles in einem Vortrag gezogen
das war vielleicht ein bisschen viel für die Leute
aber ja, also
Kubernetes geht ja glaube ich in diese Richtung,
dass die von
ihre ausführbaren Einheiten, ihre Ports
von Docker schon bereits wegabstrahiert
haben und das, was du in einem
Kubernetes-Kontext startest, es muss nicht
unbedingt ein Docker-Container sein, es könnte auch
ein Binary sein.
Und
ja, ich schätze mal, dass sich da
noch einiges in dieser Welt in den
nächsten Jahren verändern wird, dass es
mehr in solche Richtungen gehen wird wahrscheinlich.
Nicht schlecht.
Das Grundproblem ist POSIX und das gibt es damit einfach nicht mehr.
Genau, und die Mozilla-Leute haben diese Entwicklung von WebAssembly zusammen mit den Google-Chrome-Leuten natürlich dolle vorangetrieben.
Und jetzt vor ein paar Wochen ist halt noch die Spezifikation für Wasi WebAssembly System Interface losgegangen,
wo sich halt darüber unterhalten wird, über welche genauen Schnittstellen man bestimmte, zum Beispiel System Capabilities, in so eine Binary reingebt.
also quasi wie sieht das
wie sehen die System Calls aus
an welchen Stellen erwartet man jetzt ein Speicherallocator
oder ein Network Interface
oder sowas
Das ist schon cool
Ich bin gespannt was da in Zukunft noch passiert
Wer sich das angucken möchte
jetzt wo ich es eh schon eine ganze Weile drüber geredet habe
meine Slides sind auf hoody.de
slash talk slash wasm
oder in den Show Notes
Nice
Sehr cool
Krass, ja
War auf jeden Fall ein cooler Talk. Kannst gerne nochmal halten,
irgendwo anders, wo es thematisch passt.
Passt ja überall thematisch.
Allein schon die Möglichkeit,
dass man native
Anwendungen bauen kann,
die in wirklich nativen Sprachen
gebaut sind, die man nicht mehr
für jedes Target einzeln kompilieren muss.
Das ist so echt Cross-Platform.
Build once, run everywhere.
Oh mein Gott, er hat es gesagt.
Ja, das war auch so eine Sektion.
Ist das nicht einfach sowas wie Java?
Und nein.
Und warum nicht, steht in meinen Slides.
Genau.
Wie ist nochmal dieses coole Gral-VM?
Haben wir darüber gesprochen?
Was ist denn das?
Das war dieses Ding, womit du
JVM-Binaries zu nativen Code übersetzen kannst.
Glaube ich.
Sowas war das.
Es gibt irgendwie von allen JVM-Sprachen
irgendwie noch einen
Extra-Compiler, der das dann nativ macht.
Du brauchst ja nicht mehr auf die einzelnen JVM-Sprachen
targeten, wenn sie eh alle
Bytecode rausgeben. Aber ich meine trotzdem, es gibt irgendwie
Scala Native und es gibt Kotlin Native.
Stimmt, da gibt es auch eigene Projekte, hast recht.
Aber da frage ich mich
dann immer, ob die wirklich gut
auf den nativen Use Case
abbilden, weil du hast
ja ein gewisses Abstraktionsniveau
in diesen Sprachen eingebaut,
dass du dann einfach, du dann als Entwickler
keine Kontrolle drüber hast.
Es kommt halt immer, wenn du versuchst, noch Abstraktionsebene
dazwischen zu legen, dass du da halt irgendwie
durchkommen musst.
Oder möchtest.
So.
Das waren jetzt die Themen.
Jetzt suche ich noch
unser Pad wieder. Ah ja, da ist es.
Oh, hier ist
mein Gorillas-Spiel.
Hast du
GitHub-Stars?
Ah, gehen wir zu unserem klassischsten.
In den letzten Wochen, Monaten
Ja, in den letzten halben Jahren habe ich wahrscheinlich
viel gestart.
Ich habe mir eins da mal mit ins Pad reingeschrieben für heute,
weil das etwas ist, womit ich tatsächlich topaktuell gestern Abend
sehr viel Spaß hatte, bis heute früh um vier.
Und zwar ist das ein Projekt namens PostGraphile.
Klingt auch irgendwie interessant.
Das ist eine Node-Anwendung tatsächlich.
Graphile.
Ich bin sehr graphiel, graph liebend.
Die, die du auf eine Postgres-Datenbank loslässt.
Und PostgreSQL gibt dir dann direkt eine GraphQL-API
für diese Postgres-Datenbank,
beziehungsweise für diesen Table, was auch immer.
Und du hast halt, der schaust dich das Schema an,
generiert dafür passende Typen,
weil GraphQL ist ja typisiert tatsächlich,
und passende Queries,
und das kannst du noch customisen,
direkt durch Dinge in der Datenbank, was ja cool ist.
Dann kann man direkt diese Datenbank
mit so einem GraphQL-Explorer erschließen.
Du kannst sie erschließen,
du kannst passende Queries stellen,
das ist ziemlich cool.
und ziemlich mächtig auch und dadurch, dass du halt wirklich
alles in die Datenbank reinlegst, du kannst Custom Queries
in die Datenbank legen als Custom Functions,
was in Postgres ja auch super gut möglich ist,
beziehungsweise anderen
auch, aber das ist jetzt spezifisch für Postgres
und ich mache eigentlich nur Postgres, weil
ja, Postgres ist halt das
beste Punkt.
Und
du kannst halt Dinge auch passend
renamen, wenn dir das nicht passt oder
da halt noch anders
durch Plugins das Ganze noch erweitern.
Das ist ein sehr mächtiges Projekt.
es wirkt halt sehr minimal und es läuft halt innerhalb von Sekunden,
um es mal anzutesten.
Und es ist echt richtig, richtig cool.
Kann ich mal wärmerstens empfehlen, wenn da jemand mit umspielen möchte.
Das hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht,
gestern Abend dafür ein Projekt
dementsprechend umzubauen und
da dementsprechend
eine GraphQL-API für
bereitzustellen. Ah, magst du schon drüber reden, was es ist?
Ach, das ist nur dieses Park-API-Projekt, was mal...
Wollte ich gerade fragen, ob es das ist.
Was wirklich auch nach langer, langer Zeit mal
ein Rewrite benötigt. Nicht ein Rewrite, aber
kompletten Restructuring. Wir haben halt
damals, was heißt wir, ich
hab das verhauen,
ich war halt faul, als ich das
damals neu geschrieben hatte. Das ist jetzt schon der
Rewrite von was anderem.
Und das nutzt halt Postgres so ein bisschen
als NoSQL-Datenbank, aber nicht so,
wie es eigentlich, man kann Postgres
als NoSQL-Datenbank nutzen.
Oder man kann es halt einfach doof nutzen, so wie ich,
indem du als JSON-Blob einfach
da Dinge rein dumpst. Und das dann hinterher
passt. Und das hinterher passt.
Sowas hab ich auch schon gemacht, als ich 15 war.
Ja, und das ist halt echt suboptimal.
Das Projekt ist ja auch 4-5 Jahre alt
oder so und ich meine, das läuft seitdem.
Das ist komplett in Python gebaut, ne? Das ist komplett Python.
Und das ist halt blöd, weil
so ein Scraper und
ein Web-API-Dings ist, das halt
von zwei Seiten auf diese Datenbank
zugreift und ich versuche gerade aktuell
das ein bisschen auseinander zu zerren. Der Scraper,
das ist halt dank Beautiful Soup, läuft das auch gerne mit Python
weiter. Also wir müssen da auch nach wie vor
Inhalte scrapen von diversen Webseiten und Ressourcen.
Das ist ja ganz richtig,
das damit zu machen und ich versuche so
Logik, wie es nur geht, in die Datenbank zu schießen,
was super cool ist, weil die auch
super schnell ist und gerade, also ich habe
Dinge entdeckt, die ich vorher noch nicht kannte,
zum Beispiel kannst du mit einem Materialized View
in Postgres direkt
quasi den letzten gecashten Zustand
zugänglich machen, von den,
also wir haben Parkplatzdaten, die wir da gescrapen
und wenn du zum Beispiel
für eine Quelle im, Beispiel Dresden,
diesen Datenstand bereitstellen
möchtest, dann müsstest du jetzt durch die,
durch eine relativ, also nicht komplizierte
Query, aber eine Query schreiben, die halt tatsächlich
ein bisschen teuer ist, weil die sehr
viele Dateneinträge durchgehen muss, um das zu sammeln,
was da halt der jeweils letzte
Eintrag ist. Und das kann man cachen.
Und das kannst du halt durch so ein
View erstmal dir wirklich nur die Daten rausnehmen,
die du wirklich haben möchtest für diese spezifische
Query, mit den passenden zusätzlichen
Daten sammelt aus den Parkplätzen und aus der Quelle
und so weiter. Und dieser
View, den kannst du halt durch so ein Materialized
View eben cachen und hast halt
da genau den Datenstand, den du haben möchtest. Und so kann
der Scraper, wenn er neue Daten zieht, die in die
Datenbank dumpen, so ein
Async-Update für den View anstoßen,
die Datenbank refresh diesen View
und die nächsten Requests, die nehmen alle nur diese
gecacheden Daten aus diesem Review raus
und du hast diese ganze Logik in der Datenbank
schon abgebildet, die Daten sind einfach da vorgehalten,
das läuft wunderbar und
versuche ich da noch viel, viel mehr reinzulegen,
dass auch diese Forecast-Datenberechnung,
nicht die Berechnung, das müssen wir nochmal anschauen,
aber dass du halt auch so viel
wie möglich in die Datenbank legst und mit
PostGraph dann noch eine GraphQL-Data
API oben drauf, dann kannst du auch an die Daten
schön rankommen und die
passenden Queries schreiben, weil wir haben halt im Prinzip
zwei Apps, die darauf zugreifen,
die sind relativ, sagen wir mal,
die machen dieselben Queries, aber es gibt noch ein paar andere
Konsumenten mittlerweile. Das Projekt wird
mehr genutzt, als wir dachten.
Und wir haben jetzt ein paar Anfragen gehabt.
Es gibt mittlerweile Werbung in den Basler
öffentlichen Verkehrsprojekten.
Ja, das ist voll cool.
Auch beeindruckend.
Die Stadt Basel ist auf uns zugekommen.
Die haben jetzt Gelder für
Open-Data-Projekte und versuchen das
ein bisschen voranzupushen.
Und ihr allererstes Projekt, was sie damit eben,
also nicht finanzieren, aber eben, wo sie
Support für haben, war Park-API.
Stadt Basel gibt die Daten bei uns rein.
Das heißt, ihr habt Geld von denen bekommen?
Nee, kein Geld. Die haben auch
quasi nur gefragt, was können wir machen?
Oder was können wir tun, um unsere Daten bei euch drin zu haben?
Und dann haben die den PR dafür geschrieben.
Und das da reingebaut.
Hat die einen Scraper für ihre eigene Webseite gebaut?
Oder haben sie einen EDI-Entpoint?
Das sind ja Schweizer, die haben ja schöne Schnittstelle.
Genauso wie die Stadt Zürich, die auch auf uns zugekommen ist damit,
haben die einfach ein Open-Data-Portal, wo die Dinger schon als,
ich glaube, es ist sogar ein RSS-Feed in Zürich.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob in Basel auch ein Feed ist.
Auf jeden Fall, die Daten liegen schon maschinenlesbar als XML da.
Und die lassen sich sauber lesen.
Und da muss halt nichts geswapet werden.
Und es geht halt nicht kaputt.
So wie in Dresden alles in einem halben Jahr mal wieder.
Weil die halt wissen, dass die Daten halt für andere Leute von Interesse sein können.
Und sie laufen wieder rein.
es gibt halt Instant schon eine App, die die Daten halt anzeigt.
Ich meine, die App ist nicht mehr schön, weil die auch mal
ein Update verdient hat nach
Jahren. Das ist direkt mein nächstes
Projekt, nachdem ich Park API refresht habe.
Wir müssen da eine Hack-Session machen, du musst mir mal
durch dieses ganze Postgres-Ding
Aber das ist so cool, so viele Sachen
einfach in die Datenbank zu legen. Ich hab da richtig Spaß gerade.
Das ist super cool.
Auf jeden Fall.
Nee, das war mit langem
Drumherumweg jetzt mein
GitHub-Sahle-Woche Postgreifen. Ah, nein, hör nicht auf.
Na gut, okay. Was hast du denn
ich, ja hauptsächlich
so Kleinigkeiten, was ich
was ist seit, wahrscheinlich
seit kurz bevor du gegangen bist eigentlich schon gibt, ist
es gibt, oder
was während du nicht
da warst, ist stabil geworden, es ist
Firefox Send, ist jetzt
aus der Beta-Phase raus
und es ist einfach ein öffentlicher Service
von... Damit hast du mir auch immer schon unsere Folgen
geschickt. Genau, also es gibt
send.firefox.com und es ist
einfach so ein Upload-Download
Interface und das benutzen wir,
wenn ich den fertigen Schnitt von so einer
akronomisierbar-Folge zu dir
schicke. Das lade ich
hier rein. Das geht bis zu
einem Gigabyte in Größe oder wenn man
angemeldet ist mit seinem Firefox-Account
bis zweieinhalb und dann kann man angeben,
wie häufig kann das runtergeladen werden,
ist das Passwort geschützt,
wann wird es gelöscht.
Es wird per se direkt im Browser
beim Hochladen verschlüsselt
und dann wird es im Browser
beim Runterladen wieder entschlüsselt.
irgendwie mit dem Passwort, was du da angibst.
Und die Forderstellung
ist, dass es nach dem ersten Download sofort gelöscht wird.
Du kannst aber auch sagen, nach dem zweiten, dritten.
Und dafür gibt es jetzt, kommt in die Shownotes,
ein Kommandozeileninterface, wo du einfach
sagen kannst, lad das mal da unten hoch.
Sehr cool. Das ist so eine Kleinigkeit.
FF-Send heißt das Ding.
FF-Send, genau.
Und ein anderes witziges
Forschungsprojekt, was so aus
dieser Rust WebAssembly-Ecke kommt,
ist
Dodria,
ne, Dodrio, da habe ich mich vertippt,
Dodrio, und zwar
ist das eine
Virtual DOM
Implementierung in WebAssembly,
und was
Virtual DOM ist, ist der eventuell Begriff,
wenn du jetzt mit React
ein Interface baust, baut es ja
mit seinem JSX so einen
virtuellen DOM auf, und jedes Mal,
wenn du innerhalb von diesem virtuellen DOM was updatest,
wird es auf der aktuellen,
wird es in den echten DOM appliziert und
aktualisiert, und das ist
bei den meisten, gerade bei komplexeren
Web-UIs ist das
ein Bottleneck und
hier hat der
FitsGen
wie heißt denn der überhaupt wirklich?
eine
Implementierung von so einem
Virtual DOM mit
also es ist noch kein UI-Framework
ist erstmal nur ein Virtual DOM mit
einem abgefahrenen
speziellen Speicherallocator
Bump Allocator heißt es genau
implementiert und mal so gemessen,
wie sich das verhält zu dem Virtual DOM,
den zum Beispiel React mitbringt.
Und ich schreibe mir ja super schnell.
Auch Rust-Software muss ja schnell sein.
Ja, aber es gibt halt kein JSX dafür,
es gibt keine Template-Sprache,
mit der man dann seine Web-Komponenten damit beschreiben kann.
Sondern es ist erstmal so auf diesem Niveau.
Es gibt von einer anderen krassen Frau,
Bodil, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die wirklich heißt,
die hat bloß die schöne Webseite buddil.horst
oder buddil.lol
die hat
dieses typed HTML gebaut, da kannst du quasi
in Rust Makros
HTML schreiben. Das ist auch ein super cooles
Swift-Projekt, die genau das gleiche machen. Genau.
Und es gab ein
das ist alles Experimentier-Stadion
ein Projekt, wo sie
das quasi an dieses
Dodrio angeschlossen haben, so als
aber es ist
Das Klientel ist sehr passend. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Die Frau hat, das ist eigentlich eine
richtige Empfehlung, das fehlt hier noch
drin, auf bodil.lol
oder bodil.horse
kommt in die Liste.
Die hat neulich einen
introductory Blogpost
zum Thema Parserkombinatoren
in Rust geschrieben und ich
hab mir das erstmal in mein Pocket reingezogen und
bei Pocket rechnet ihr aus, wie lange das dauert,
das zu lesen, da stand was von 52 Minuten.
Also das war, das ist
kein Blogpost, die hat auch auf Twitter geschrieben
I wrote a rather longish blog post
on this subject.
I wrote a book.
Ich hab das zur Hälfte durch.
Bislang ist es halt wirklich,
wenn du sowas im Moment selber bauen willst,
kannst du das lesen.
Das ist definitiv spannend,
wenn man sich mit Parsern
und mit Parserkombinatoren auseinandersetzen möchte.
Das kommt in die Liste.
Was ich eigentlich zu diesem Dodri noch dazu sagen wollte,
das war bloß so ein Versuch.
Kann man solche Sachen mit Rewrite it in Rust
schneller machen und verglichen
mit den JavaScript-Implementierungen
von so Virtual-Dom-Geschichten
definitiv schneller.
Also meistens schneller.
In wenigen Fällen manchmal
aus unergründlichen Gründen langsamer.
Aber meistens schneller.
Sehr unerfindliche Gründe.
Und vor ein paar Tagen ist Version 3 von Svelte
rausgekommen.
Oh, okay.
Und Svelte...
Genau.
Und damit habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit
auch mal wieder rumgespielt.
Der Rich Harris hat auch einen sehr schönen
introductory Vortrag gehalten.
als YouTube-Video würde ich hier noch mit, also wir
packen einfach alles in diese Folge, die ist jam-packed.
Wir müssen aber auch sehr viel nachholen.
Vortrag darüber gehalten,
wie cool es Welt ist,
weil man schreibt irgendwie nur halb so viel Code wie bei
React und es ist vorkompiliert und
es ist eine
einfachere Syntax und
es ist ein kleineres Endergebnis
und es ist wesentlich schneller,
weil es kein Virtual DOM hat, sondern
weil es irgendwie, das hat es mit
Excel verglichen.
Was? Ja.
ich verweise wie gesagt auf den Talk
und
da hat er zum Beispiel in diesem Talk auch
dieses Dotrio drin gehabt, ja wie kann man jetzt Virtual DOM
schneller machen, man könnte ihn in Rust neu
schreiben, ja ist schneller, aber
übrigens Svelte nimmt überhaupt kein Virtual DOM
und ist noch schneller als diese Rust Implementierung
und das ist pures JavaScript, schon ziemlich krass
also ich hab ja mit
ich hab jetzt mal so eine kleine Chat-Anwendung
privat gebaut und baue das damit
und Svelte ist echt, ich mach nicht viel
Frontend, aber Svelte ist echt schön
hast ja damals schon mal
sehr geliebäugelt mit
und ein bisschen coole Sachen gezeigt
genau, kann ich vielleicht in der nächsten Folge, wenn ich das zu Ende gemacht habe
das Projekt ein bisschen mehr dazu erzählen
ok
ja, das waren unsere GitHub Stars der Woche
hoffen wir wieder, dass wir in Zukunft
wieder weitere coole Projekte finden
auf jeden Fall
ne, eine Sache kann man noch machen, und zwar haben wir ein paar Podcast-Empfehlungen
möglicherweise ein paar, mindestens eine
ja, es ist eine Menge Zeit ins Land gegangen
da muss man natürlich Podcasts hören
auf jeden Fall, und zwar möchte ich empfehlen
Podcast Space Tourist
oder Space Tourist, einfach auf Deutsch,
von dem Stefan Majewski,
der auch schon mal Gast hier mit war.
Gast, der hat die
letzte Kongress-Folge quasi
fast alleine geschmissen.
Still Really in Noises heißt ja
sein Podcast-Label, kann man ja fast
sagen, hat er jetzt damit jetzt den zweiten Podcast.
Und der geht in dieser Folge
einfach mal durch diverse,
aktuell gibt es nur eine Folge, also plant durch
diverse Hackerspaces im deutschsprachigen
Raum zu gehen und den einfach mal einen Besuch
abzustatten, um mit denen über ihren Hackerspace zu
labern. Das finde ich ziemlich cool. Geile Sache, auf jeden Fall.
Also, als er
für seinen Podcast
gar nicht mal so einfach,
gar nicht so einfach,
so ein Plug abgegeben hat
in der Folge, die wir auf dem Kongress
aufgenommen hatten,
hatte ich den auch noch gar nicht gehört
und noch gar nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt.
Und ich habe mir die
drei, vier, fünf Folgen, die er da
gemacht hat, zwischendurch mal angehört
Das ist super informativ und erstaunlich qualitativ.
Das Production Quality
hat so ein bisschen was von so einem NPR-Podcast,
muss ich sagen.
Die ist so ein bisschen neidisch geworden.
Ich meine, wir haben ja hier gewollt ein Laber-Format,
aber eigentlich solche Podcasts würde ich auch gerne machen.
Das ist wirklich, wo man sich ein Skript überlegt
und Dinge sauber einspricht.
Ja, aber er hat gemeint, dass er echt Stunden braucht,
um so eine einzelne Folge irgendwie einzusprechen.
Die letzte Folge, die er herausgebracht hat,
waren einfach bloß Outtakes.
Sehr gut auf jeden Fall. Also alles, was
der Stefan Majewski so im Podcast-Universum
macht, wärmstens empfohlen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und es gibt eine Folge, da war
er dann wo?
Er hat natürlich
zugemacht. Die Folge kam halt vor einer Weile
schon wieder raus.
Also er war bisher im
Eigenbau-Kombinat Halle.
Aber ich hoffe auch noch
mehr coole Sachen in Zukunft.
Nice
Ich bin ja eigentlich
nebenbei Hobbymusiker
und ich habe so ein paar
Musikpodcasts bei mir an der Liste
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die schon mal erzählt habe
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die wirklich, wirklich cool sind
Und ich habe wahrscheinlich schon davon erzählt
Es gibt einen, der heißt Switched on Pop
Wenn du jetzt nicht jemand bist, der dir gesagt
Ich höre nur Metal oder nur Hip-Hop oder sowas
Wenn du ein bisschen offener bist für Musik
Zum Beispiel auch für aktuelle Popmusik
ist der eigentlich extrem empfehlenswert,
weil da reden zwei Songwriter
oder Produzenten miteinander über
Taylor Swift oder über
was ist jetzt gerade aktuell,
Billie Eilish. Teilweise mit den
Musikern selber und wie so ein Album zustande
gekommen ist und das ist definitiv
sehr gut, über den habe ich glaube ich schon mal geredet.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich auch schon mal über
Song Exploder
geredet. Song Exploder
ist ein sehr geiles Format, wo ein
konkreter Song genommen wird und dann mit dem
Künstler, was ist hier das letzte,
Mumford's and Sons oder
Hosea,
oder was weiß ich,
viele Sachen kenne ich gar nicht,
gehen die dieses eine Lied durch und
reden über jedes einzelne Instrument, über jedes
Sample, was sie da genommen haben, wie das zustande gekommen ist,
die Geschichte dazu und zum Schluss spielen sie
das Lied dann im Ganzen ab.
Das ist so, wenn du diese einzelnen Sachen,
die einzelne Erklärungen davon gehört hast und du
dann zum Schluss diese Lied dann hörst und nochmal so richtig bewusst
irgendeinen
wieder, also von vorne bis hinten und mit der Erklärung,
was der sich bei dem Text gedacht hat, gehört.
Also gerade mit der Erklärung war das natürlich
echt was her. Richtig gut, auf jeden Fall.
Die beiden habe ich eventuell schon mal erwähnt und was
jetzt neulich neu in meiner Liste dazu gekommen ist,
ist Strong Songs, was auch
ein Musik- und Spielejournalist,
der
einfach auch Musiker ist,
sich jedes Mal einen Song nimmt und den
komplett analysiert und da hat er halt
eine Folge über
Bohemian Rhapsody gemacht
von Michael Jackson
und eine Folge zum Beispiel, was
wirklich sehr, sehr spannend war,
über Let It Go aus Frozen.
Und
da ist mittendrin eine
Stelle, wo du denkst, hey, was haben sie denn hier gemacht?
Da haben sie so einen ganz komischen halbtaktigen
Übergang von dem einen in den
anderen Teil gemacht, weil es die
Harmonie-Folge war,
war, was
weiß ich, A, B, C und in dem nächsten Teil
war es B, C,
A, so ein bisschen verrutscht einfach
in der Harmoniefolge, da haben sie einfach so einen komischen
Füller reingebaut.
Das sind so die Sachen, höre ich
sehr, sehr gerne beim Auffaschen.
Ich meine, wenn wir sehe schon bei
Podcasts zur Musik sind, kann man auch
gleich nochmal eine Empfehlung abgeben für den
fantastischen Podcast Sekunde Mal
von zwei unseren Bekannten.
Ach, stimmt, ja. Von Lukas und Lars.
Sehr kurze Folgen, kann man
auf jeden Fall mal schnell durchhören, sind aktuell auch nur
sechs plus null, also sieben
Stück. Sehr unterhaltsam.
Ich finde die großartig und wünsche mir
gibt es noch viel, viel mehr.
Das waren Lukas und Lars.
Genau.
Ja, die erste Folge war ein Tick anstrengend.
Aber ich nehme den definitiv mal wieder in meine Liste.
Die aktuelle fand ich auch sehr cool
zu Earcons, wo sie über
hörbare Icons
reden. Unter anderem über die
Sounds, die die
DVB abspielt beim Türen schließen oder beim
Ansage machen.
Das ist das, woran du merkst,
wenn du mit dem Zug nach Brandenburg
fährst. Das ist nämlich ab einem gewissen
Punkt diese Einspieler,
also wenn du mit der
Regional-Bimmelbahn fährst, ab einem
gewissen Punkt sind die Einspieler für
wie der nächste Ort heißt mit einer anderen Melodie
und der Lektion.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ah, ich bin jetzt nicht mehr
in Sachsen, ich bin jetzt in Brandenburg.
Nice.
Ich habe schon mal darüber
bemerkt.
Weißt du, wie
viel Zeit schon wieder vergangen ist?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Das ist anderthalb Stunden.
Krass. Ja, dann würde ich sagen, können wir auch hier mal
grob einen Schlussstrich wieder ziehen für heute.
Ja, das war die erste akronomisierbare
Folge nach der längeren Pause.
Und die erste Folge wieder mit Knien.
Aber es ist noch nicht die erste 2019, oder? Oder doch?
Nee, die erste 2019
gab es schon im Januar. Ich wollte ja zwischendurch so ein paar
Interviewfolgen machen,
aber das habe ich nur
bedingt durchhalten können, weil es halt
auch extrem zeitaufwendig ist, vor allem
Leute ranzukriegen und zu finden.
Dementsprechend habe ich es dann irgendwann nicht mehr ganz geschafft.
Aber vielleicht, wenn wir uns das gegenseitig mal wieder öfter dran erinnern,
dann kriegen wir mal wieder Gäste dazu.
Finde ich cool, auf jeden Fall.
Ihr könnt es auch gerne, habe ich jetzt mal eingerichtet,
Hendrik ist noch nicht mit drin, aber hoffentlich gleich,
uns schreiben.
Ich habe mal den Raum akonominierbar auf matrix.org mit aufgemacht.
Als generell...
Hat das nicht schon?
Nö, wir hatten den Chat zwischen uns beiden.
Aber wir hatten nicht wirklich den Raum.
Auch wenn der Chat genauso ist.
Das heißt, ich bin da jetzt schon drin?
Ich habe dich eingeladen vor drei Monaten.
Oh, zwei Monaten.
Aber du musst natürlich auch Matrix nutzen,
beziehungsweise Write aufmachen, den Client.
Aber wenn ihr Matrix nutzt, in welcher Form auch immer,
schaut da gerne mal vorbei.
Ich würde mich freuen, einfach mal mit jemandem da zu schreiben,
beziehungsweise Feedbacks zu bekommen
oder einfach generell Themenvorschläge,
was auch immer, ihr wollt Gast sein oder auch nicht.
Das vor allem,
ich unterhalte mich ja sehr gerne mit Leuten,
die mehr wissen als ich oder andere Sachen wissen als ich.
Ich behaupte, sehr viele Leute wissen sehr viel mehr als wir beide.
Auf jeden Fall. Und die möchte ich alle
hier in dieser Sendung zu ihren
speziellen Themen
in unserem sehr unstrukturierten
Interview-Format zu Gast haben.
Ja, wollen wir auf jeden Fall mal haben.
Also meldet euch,
beziehungsweise wir finden euch.
Und diesmal machen wir mal ein bisschen was anders.
Wir machen jetzt nicht den Countdown
zum Schluss.
Das war die nächste Folge
in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in...
Ich habe diesmal Musik.
Sehr cool. Was für Musik hast du denn?
Haha, und zwar gibt es einen Gangster-Rapper, der nennt sich STD Out auf YouTube. Also sucht man nach Dollar STD Out auf YouTube, gibt es mittlerweile so 10 Lieder oder sowas.
Und als ich diese Musik gehört habe, habe ich mir gedacht, ja, ja, ich sehe mich in dieser Musik wieder.
Als Teenager hast du gegen deine Eltern rebelliert.
Als erwachsener Softwareentwickler rebellierst du gegen deine Manager oder gegen Scrum oder gegen das System oder gegen das Leben als Softwareentwickler.
Und genau das bringt dieser Rapper in seinen Texten zum Ausdruck.
Na dann lass damit mal das Auto einspielen.
Damit verabschieden wir uns von euch.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und jetzt kommt die Kultur.
I like Ruby, I like Go
But strong typing for the win
Adam over VS Code
And VS Code over Vim
I like spaces over tabs
Underscores over dash
80 characters per line
And 100 lines per class
I like only double quotes
Semicolons for the close
If you don't do what I like, then your pull request is froze.
I don't like this naming style.
I think we should move this filing.
Can we add a comment here?
Please just let me commandeer.
Got opinions on opinions about how we should operate.
Deviations from the style got I just cannot tolerate.
I need my code consistent.
Not one indentation missing.
So please install my linter because I don't like when it's different.
You should write code like I write it.
Yeah, you should write code like I write it.
You should like it if I like it.
Trust my choice and tag along.
Cause I am right and you are wrong.
You should write code like I write it.
You should like it if I like it.
Trust my choice and tag along.
Cause I am right and you are wrong.
Please don't call me OCD.
It's the only way to be.
I can't let you code with me.
If you never worked in C, or don't practice TDD, or aren't down with IRC, or don't read
XKCD, or you use MongoDB, can we add some unit tests?
We use SAS, not CSS, JSON API requests.
My opinion never ends, I'm just waiting to suggest.
I'll recommend a standing desk, tell you which coffee is best.
Bitcoin's hot, you should invest.
Got opinions on opinions about how you should live your life.
Deviations from the style, God ain't just about the code you write.
Still I need my code consistent, not one indentation missing
So please install my linter cause I don't like when it's different
You see, but that line about Vim, it doesn't make sense
Because Vim is actually the best editor, it's the best kind of coffee
They're always a bit slow, and they're also, if you use editor like AdSign, not even of no stuff
You should write code like I write it
Yeah, you should write code like I write it
You should like it if I like it
Trust my choice and tag along
Cause I am right and you are wrong
You should write code like I write it
You should like it if I like it
Trust my choice and tag along
Cause I am right and you are wrong
Verarscht.
Nächste Folge in 3, 2, 1.